so remember how like uh those Banks were
collapsing and we were really concerned
about one of them and they said no
everything's fine you don't got to worry
about that one Bank well now we got to
worry about that one bank it's uh First
Republic and not only are we getting
reports that they've basically
mismanaged funds they're being sued uh I
think it's like 72 billion dollars
something like that we're hearing now
from a a fox business reporter that the
U.S May seize this bank now what your
Guru says that the US government is
expected to actually seize this bank and
uh it's a decently large Bank a lot of
people have money here and so our money
there so it's um I don't know I guess
it's worrying there was some other news
I guess the other day that I didn't
report on I just don't really care
there's a who's who's that who's that
guy who's running for announcing the run
for President Biden oh Joe Biden
announced is going to be running for a
re-election or something I just I just
don't care I really don't it's just not
news so there's that then there's a Fox
News losing one billion dollars in
market value firing Tucker Carlson and
the entire Dylan Mulvaney Fox news I got
a great opportunity there but now we're
hearing that they're losing a bunch of
Fox Nation subscribers which is all just
completely obvious and I think one thing
people haven't mentioned is that maybe
the reason Rupert Murdoch wanted to get
rid of him is simply because he was
becoming the face of Fox News and that's
a threat to Fox News they want Fox News
to be the brand not Tucker Carlson so
we'll talk about all that stuff but
before we do my friends we had an
amazing sponsor tonight cast Brew Coffee
head over to castbrew.com and pick up
your coffee today it's a pre-order we'll
Ship by May 5th and you can get one of
two signature Blends rise with Roberto
Jr why in fact Roberto Jr is our rooster
and Appalachian nights a robust dark
blend we also have Colombian and French
roast this is our company so when you
buy cast Brew Coffee not only are you
supporting the show you're getting good
coffee now how that's pretty pretty good
deal isn't it we're going to be
launching decaf we have a bunch of
really good names uh thanks to our
members sleepy Joe blend which is uh oh
yeah that was from our Discord word
sleepy Joe because you know Joe coffee
and sleepy because there's no caffeine
and then stand your grounds which is
going to be another roast so those are
going to be rolling out in the next
month or so but uh once we get the
official production line rolling which
is about May 5th when you start
receiving your coffee we are going to
launch coffee subscriptions we are going
to be having this as our principal
product at our coffee shop in West
Virginia and we're gonna be expanding a
lot more so with your support cast brew
coffee will be a coffee company that is
not scared to be associated with with
good honest young men who believe in
their community and things like that if
you get madrift don't forget to also
head over oh that's castbrew.com don't
forget to also head over to timcast.com
click that join us button become a
member to support the show directly and
you will get access to our Discord
server where you can hang out with
like-minded individuals share ideas you
can actually call into the show the
uncensored members only show which as a
member you get access to Monday through
Thursday at 10 10 pm you can actually
submit questions and be one of our
callers if you've been a member for at
least six months or sign up at the 25
per month level so smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends joining us
today to talk about this and so much
more is Layton Woodhouse hello
sir who are you I'm a journalist I have
a sub stack called public which I run
with Michael schellenberger been
reporting for a long time about crime
homelessness drugs in the Bay Area
that's where I live that's where Michael
lives as well as about the censorship
industrial complex we were both part of
the Twitter files yeah that's who I am
yeah right on I saw Tim Robbins was uh
was I saw that too tweeted about your
work so this is the guy from a bunch of
Shawshank Shawshank Redemption right
yeah and um he's in he's got a new movie
coming out but this is like a he's a big
movie star and he's also like an old
school leftist like right traditional
kind of leftist yeah it seems like a few
of them left I guess yeah and then and
he tweeted about the censorship
industrial complex he tweeted out your
work so very based so uh good to have
you here man looking forward to hanging
out with you absolutely and uh shim sham
my name's Seamus Coughlin I have a
YouTube channel called Freedom Tunes
where we make animated cartoons we just
released a video today that I think you
guys are really going to enjoy I also
have a stream on Rumble it's a podcast
called shamer we stream Tuesdays and
Thursdays at 6 PM but we are going to be
streaming every single day this week so
if you all want to go over there and
check either of those channels out I
would be grateful right on and welcoming
back to the show is Adrian Norman what's
going on guys Adrian Norman here I am a
staff writer here at timcast and like
Casper coffee I am also a robust dark
blend
oh there you go uh he's not Ian but you
know adrenal tries best I guess yeah you
know see if we can do how does Tim treat
you as as an employee writing for Tim
Cass oh we're just going to start here
give us he's actually you know so uh
he's like one of the few people who
doesn't actually live out here you know
he he's very privileged in that regard
you can just go wherever he wants and we
have to fly him in you know take care of
him get him on the show you know what I
mean he's you're not like Dave about or
anything right no no yeah yeah good well
I'm glad he's yelling me over Slack
right on uh yeah it should be fun and
then of course we got surge pressing all
the buttons what's up guys sir.com
all right well let's just jump into this
first story I guess it's this is a big
deal and I don't know how worried you
guys are but we have this from Watcher
Guru First Republic Bank expected to be
seized by U.S government wow uh First
Republic Bank is expected to be seized
by the US government report by Fox
Business Network says according to
Charles gasparino Bankers working with
First Republic say they expect eventual
government receivership of the for the
LA Bank this will come after it exhausts
private sector Solutions such as asset
sales and finding a buyer both of which
appear difficult not surprised First
Republic lost more than 40 percent of
its deposits approximately 72 billion
dollars in the first quarter of this
year holy crap that's bad it's shares
sank nearly 50 as the end of Tuesday
this is according to a Monday
Announcement by the bank the bank has
seen record drops over the past month
and a half particularly since the
Silicon Valley bank was closed in March
multiple big banks have also struggled
however it looks like First Republic
will be falling into the hands of the
U.S government soon
uh they're also they're going to be
doing that Central Bank digital currency
in June or something I've heard about
that so this is all like kind of good
timing what if this is what precipitates
an emergency buyout we were talking
about this the last time there was a
banking crisis which was like three
weeks ago and uh so yeah and the idea is
like the banks start crumbling then the
US government steps in and says we are
going to rescue your deposits good
members of First Republic Bank simply
download the FED app and we will convert
your US Dollars into fedcoin which you
can then use to purchase Goods
I'll tell you guys if that happens
because I'm this whole discussion is
stressing me out I'm experiencing some
existential angst because that's my bank
that's my that's my bank uh that I Bank
in it's also the bank that owns the
mortgage for my house so that well that
might be good news I it might be I have
no idea like what am I cool you know
we've got direct deposits going into
this Bank we've got like I just told my
we just learned about this what like
half an hour ago or something yeah I
told my wife we don't know what's
happening with our money I mean we're
well under the FDIC cap so we'll get
insured for that but to be fair you've
had like a month to prepare for this
because we knew First Republic was in
Dire Straits I believe their PR
statements they're like we're secure I
actually think that I mean I don't know
anything about this but I do think that
they're just taking backsplash from what
happened with Silicon Valley Bank so I
kind of doubt that this is a fundamental
issue with a bank I think that this is
part of a panic which is a reason why I
should have joined the panic and taking
my money out myself or maybe by not
panicking you may have helped them yeah
but they lost 40 percent of the deposits
yeah I mean that sounds like
mismanagement they're being sued
apparently
hold on right there a minute wouldn't it
be cool to wake up everybody listen you
wake up one day and you get a phone call
and they're like you know that mortgage
you had in your house it's gone
for 300 000 Boop actually during the in
2009 during the the banking crisis with
a financial crisis was when I bought my
first house in LA and I had this
experience I've never heard anybody have
this experience before I put in an offer
on this house it was super cheap because
it was like a short sale you know it was
like property was super cheap obviously
right after the crash and um and they
sat on the offer for a while they came
back to me like three weeks later and
they said my agent called me he was like
I don't know can't make heads or tails
out of this but the the the bank wants
you is asking if you are willing to
lower your offer by fifty thousand
dollars and if that happens we'll clear
it and you'll get the house and I did it
and I got the house absolutely not no I
want to pay fifty thousand dollars more
but I guess the issue with like would
the buyer accept or the seller it was
like I think the best I can make of it
is like there was nobody who actually
owned the house because these are all
securitized loans it was like you know
some Chinese Southern wealth fund and
you know pension fund or whatever so
nobody actually had equity in the house
but the bank that was holding the debt
on it was just losing money every month
oh that was on the market so they just
wanted it was a toxic asset they just
wanted to get off market and what they
were afraid of is if they took the the
the offer that I accepted the appraiser
would come in who used to be super you
know these appraisers used to be super
like corrupt and arm hand and glove with
the with the Realtors but all of a
sudden they were super honest and um and
so they were afraid that the appraiser
was going to come in and say no this is
not worth as much as you're offering and
then the deal would fall part and then
they'd have it on their their books for
months longer so that's the best I can
make sense of it
First Republic said Monday it lost a net
total of 72 billion dollars in deposits
during the first quarter an outflow that
would have topped 100 billion if not for
a rescue from 11 of the law of the
nation's largest bank so this is like
people are it's a run in the bank yeah
that's this this sounds like people are
rushing to the the bank and getting
their money I'm worried uh it's kind of
scary there was another story did you
guys hear PNC is shutting down like 40
some odd branches wow no no dude I
wonder if the banking system is going
and and we're like on the Titanic just
oblivious is like the banking system and
the media at the same time
dude the media uh Nate silver got fired
yeah buzzfeed's gone BuzzFeed news
Jimmy Stewart to be like oh the money's
not in the bank it's in your neighbor's
home and in their business so they don't
believe their money there I think the
first thing Adrian you did was like you
looked up Jim Cramer
[Laughter]
he literally said but no you pulled it
up right before the show and you're like
oh he said it's what do you say it's a
safe Bank he could be right like
fundamental FRC is new Focus very good
bank
it's only the man is undefeated he will
not lose I mean I I I'm really
considering using him as an inverse
financial advisor you know what I mean
just like whatever he says you do the
opposite he's like the George Costanza
Finance dude with Nancy Pelosi and Jim
Cramer you should know exactly what to
invest in you have no excuse that's
that's true yeah whatever Nancy Pelosi
invests in and whatever Jim Cramer
advised you to do you do the opposite
he's like don't do he's like Nancy's
headed for bankruptcy you don't invest
in anyone is
I don't know what this means though am I
supposed to be worried like should we
Panic you should always panicked him
I should I should always always Panic
that's a good rule of thumb
I want to try and pull up this news look
at this one this is this is like we
never actually covered this story even
though it's from April 4th
can I close this or something what is
this PNC Bank set to close 47 branches
across the U.S by end of June wow so uh
if you got First Republic or PNC I guess
the challenging thing is does reporting
on it just contribute to a run on the
bank and like make everything worse I
think yes the banking system that was it
was a matter of time because the whole
thing operates on on confidence and
Faith right yeah I mean they have a
system of fractional Reserve lending
where if you put in 100 bucks you know
the bank can lend out 90 of it and only
hold 10 yeah and the only thing that's
holding the system together is everybody
not going to the bank at the same time
to take the money out which is exactly
what's happening right now but they're
actually lend out a hundred They removed
the reserve requirement well they put it
20. I think they put it back someone's
super chatted so they put it back but
it's it's not that they can learn at 90.
it's that they can create ninety dollars
so if there's a hundred dollars in the
bank they create 90 new dollars on that
100 so now there's 190 in the money
supply I thought I thought they could
actually multiply it by 10 right because
they only need 10 in reserve so if they
have a hundred dollars they can create
nine hundred dollars like what happened
with the bow out was the FED issued out
like 425 billion so that could be
leveraged to give 4.2 trillion in loans
out like I I'm not sure my understanding
was that you put 100 in the bank they
create 90 in loans so they still have
the 100 and that's another 90 and then
someone who gets that 90 deposits it in
a different bank so now there's 100 here
90 here that bank then loans out you
know uh 80 81 or whatever and so 100
turns into a thousand dollars and that's
inflation yeah no but but I actually
think because you only have to have 10
on hand they can literally say we have a
hundred dollars therefore we're able to
lend out 900 as opposed to 90. I think
you guys are saying the same thing
you're saying no but he said well he's
saying 90. yeah so I'm just being like
they could like loan that 90 out but
they're not loading it out they're
creating it create well yes like crazy
yeah let me resolve this if somebody
puts a hundred dollars into a bank they
create
um 900 because they're because that's
ten percent right so that gives them the
ability to be able to I don't think
that's how that works they they can loan
out 90 of the deposits oh I hear what
you're saying okay yeah so if they
receive a hundred dollars they keep they
cannot hand but what I'm saying yeah
they keep 100 on hand and then create
90. I think that do they or do they just
actually issue it out because a lot of
these Banks don't have the cash on hand
when people come to withdraw and that's
why they collapse so I think they
actually do pass the money out no
someone's saying it's 900 not 90. yeah
yeah not in the sense 100 deposit is 1
000 in new money loans yeah if they lend
the money out it's not Sheamus is right
okay
well so everybody else's bank account
though we don't we don't actually fact
check we just ask the audience the
audience the audience says I'm right
this is the popularity yeah I got no
idea I mean I'm not I'm not a finance
guy so I just uh I'll defer to the
cartoonist
that's a brilliant strategy look if you
can make a living making cartoons you're
good with money that's all I'll say even
if you can stretch that dollar dude it
was then an anti-semitic joke what no it
was an anti-media he's Irish
uh no one here is panicking though like
you're like I'm kind of affordable well
you got held on you got a house fifty
thousand dollars cheaper and right after
the crash so if you get a break okay but
I might get a free house now excellent
oh well that would be nice yeah what
happens like the bank the government
bails out of the government owns your
house I have no idea what happens what
if Joe Biden no I just like we're on
your house it's in our house man you
can't own a house it's everyone's house
man oh man that's what he said about
kids today so here's our your children
it's the nation's children I was like
what
excuse me the state owns your kids you
can't tell someone not to sniff your kid
man it's we're all paying taxes for that
hair
I don't think he said that that's
exactly what he said you fact check me
have the chat fact check me on it Tim
uh all right chat did Joe Biden actually
say he's allowed to smell your kids I'm
they're gonna say he did that was the
Spirit
hold on that was
what she said between the lines
First Republic Bank shares splitting
here 49 after earnings report I mean
like the
story is I can opine for days on like
ABC News firing Nate Smith I'm sorry
Nate silver and uh BuzzFeed collapsing
and Don Lemon getting fired and Tucker
getting fired but like the banking
system collapsing I'm kind of just like
well I'm glad I bought Bitcoin or
something I don't know it's like as a
millennial who's lived through two major
Financial crises I'm kind of not phased
by Banks falling apart and what that
means and especially considering you
know I got chickens so I'm I'm not I'm
not worried about it are you confident
in Bitcoin yeah yeah well I'm more
confident in the chickens to be honest
that's true though I I am more confident
in the chickens what do you make of the
idea that that crypto is actually the
vehicle that's going to be used to bring
in the cbdcs I mean it is that literally
is what they're doing like this the
Central Bank digital currencies are
crypto based currencies that they're
they're making the Bitcoin of course the
precursor but I've actually argued this
for a while that Bitcoin was the most
convenient way to get anti-establishment
conspiracy type individuals to embrace
Global Currency you have people like
Alex Jones being locked I want a One
World Government with one currency
Romero the Euro and then all of a sudden
around the time he's complaining about
the Amero an American single North
American single currency Bitcoin pops up
no one knows who made it and then
immediately it's all of these people who
want to buy it so it's like convince the
one group of people who would reject a
Global Currency to to adopt the Global
Currency and you've won you've you've
controlled that position your way
through the the barricade you know yeah
well and this is part of what is very
confusing right I mean conservatism
doesn't have a solid definition or solid
footing at the present moment it's a
little bit of we're just gonna do the
opposite of what the left is doing and a
little bit of we're just going to do the
opposite of what the establishment is
doing the idea of Bitcoin is certainly
not a conservative idea right that's a
very new interesting Innovative idea it
doesn't make it a bad one I think there
could be value to it but what
conservatism is supposed to be about
conserving yeah I would say it's more of
a return and it's not to say that
conservatives can't have any thinking
which overlaps with libertarianism and
it would be reasonable to say because
this government is so horrible and does
things so badly and as it's drawing our
currency it makes sense for
conservatives to look into crypto if
that's the particular heads they've
chosen this is not Financial advice
but we have not yes we don't have a
cohesively defined movement well I guess
we'll see what happens with these Banks
and um I'm not going to give anybody
Financial advice but I'll just tell you
I've I'm I've already been looking at
means of storing value elsewhere because
with PNC closing I think was a 47
branches that's very scary you know I
mean that's like that might be bigger
news than a Regional Bank collapsing
because PNC is a major Bank they're
they're all over the East Coast
maybe 47 is not that many compared to
how many branches they have I guess it's
an important question but all of this
happening in one thing about Silicon
Valley and First Republic is that
they're like high-end banks for you know
affluent people they do like first
Republicans main business is wealth
management so I don't know about PNC
because we don't I don't think I guess
we do have it on the West Coast but it's
not very very present is it no they're
just like normal gas stations yeah
they're like Wawa and stuff like that
right right so I don't know what
conclusions draw from the fact that it's
these like Elite banks that are falling
but in Australia they announced that
some of their big banks are going to
stop giving out cash
you go to the bank you're like I'd like
money like you can't have it yup yeah
and the reason why is they said it's
because everyone's using mobile apps so
nobody needs the physical location to
withdraw cash anymore he's got an ATM
which is the precursor to your money
only exists on the internet yeah and
then Central Bank digital currency I've
actually wondered many times what that
what this means for panhandlers
you're gonna have any cares cash anymore
right you're going to tap your card
you're going to walk up and go boom and
then they're going to be alive thank you
sir and you're like they're gonna hold
out the keypad and you're gonna go
through you know you're gonna type in
the number that's actually actually
interesting I wonder if like the global
Elites are trying to eliminate that kind
of thing panhandling I mean maybe you'll
hand them a bottle of water or a
sandwich well in my city there are
sometimes homeless people who have like
a cash app thing out on their side yeah
no yep yeah that's not there's no way no
I'm not kidding cash app yes and then
people walk up the thing is like there
are a lot of homeless people who just
have like really cheap smartphones
nowadays so they get seriously they'll
get like a 20 phone from qriket or
something or whatever the inexpensive
phone uh YouTube is now you're talking
about down in Georgia yeah yeah so
you're saying I could go to a big city
and just sit in a lawn chair and put up
a sign with a cash up and say give me
money and then people will just send me
money yeah you look the role we should
you know we should do we should put a
cash app thing on on timcast like right
down here in the corner and just like
speaking of questions please give me
your money I know this isn't on the
docket but did you guys read this report
it was like a month ago or something
about how cash app and the entire what's
the name of it it's not Square anymore
it's like Cube or something like that
whatever the company is Jack dorsey's
company I think it's still square is it
still Square yeah might be a different
one okay the the entire
um app is basically like most of its
Revenue comes from like sex trafficking
drug deal oh my God wait wait Jack
dorsey's way what it was like it was a
very exhaustive report about how cash
app is just built straight up on Black
Market activity we have to make cash app
safe for the black market which is why
we're banning all legal activity on
Crash so wait wait wait cash app
where did you find this it was this
report that was issued that they took
issue with but the report was very
detailed I read a lot of it um uh it was
exhaustive I didn't read the whole thing
because I I I've got Square shares you
know I got a handful of them yeah you
should read that report oh yeah it was
like I don't know it was maybe like 10
years ago or something or eight years
ago someone told me this Rich dude who
lived in New York I was hanging out with
Max Kaiser and he was just like you got
to buy Square stock because everything's
going digital transactions and I was
like okay I guess and then I bought a
little bit and then it like went tenfold
in value I was like wow the other thing
I remember in this report is that
there's all these rappers who are
straight up bragging about it in their
raps so they're like they're like
another thing that it funds is a lot of
like um like Hitmen are hired via cash
app and there's these rappers who like
some of whom have been charged with
murder after say after reciting these
lyrics who are like hit me on cash app
and they're talking about like doing
hits on people oh my gosh so it's like
it's like in the and then Jack Dorsey I
think I remember from this report at one
point was like in an interview was
talking about how grateful he is to all
the the publicity he's gotten from these
from these rappers
oh my gosh this is the guy who thinks
that using the offensive pronouns for
person on Twitter makes them unsafe and
he's like come here's my murder app
so let's talk about somebody else who's
losing money check this out from the
postman you know fox fox loses one
billion dollars after parting ways of
Tucker Carlson the fox Corporation stock
plummeted as much as five percent on
Monday wiping out 930 million dollars in
market value following the announcement
that Fox News had parted ways with
Tucker Carlson according to Business
Insider shares the media company
recovered slightly after so it dropped
it ended up at like 29 the decision to
part ways with Carlson
announce less than a week after Fox
Corporation Dominion voting blah blah
blah Carlson was one of the Network's
most popular hosts blah blah blah you
know I saw some really interesting
commentary from Glenn Greenwald you
wanna know what he said how come the
left doesn't care about Hannity
how come the left doesn't complain about
handy or Laura Ingram
and they he said it's because Tucker is
the only one who was anti-war and
anti-big Pharma yeah so the left went
after him and completely ignores the
safe GOP
and that's what Fox News wants to be
they don't want Tucker Carlson coming
out here and saying these things yeah
they want someone to go on and just be
like big corporations are great
everybody just do what the government
says exactly they would love that a
Tucker one honors like the left wants
you to think that these corporations
doing bad things to America they're our
best friends actually they do great
things
thank you
um but I sort of mentioned this
yesterday that CNN is the network that
tells you what you're supposed to
believe and then Fox is the network that
tells you what you're allowed to believe
so if you don't want to buy into what
CNN is saying they'll push you over to
Fox and that's still within the realm of
acceptable opinion but Tucker's a little
Bridge Too Far yeah he's a bridge a
little too far it's too far man yeah
yeah then he actually says something you
know cable news commentators they're all
buzzwords apparently now they got the
sync he launch this thing on his website
where it's like you can text some number
to like Tucker to 4-4 or something or
whatever and then they'll send you
information on what he's planning to do
or something like that oh really yeah
it's like you'll get it you'll get
notified when he announces his next big
move or whatever I think Tucker
Carlson's gonna end up making 100
million bucks a year off this
termination Fox if Fox was paying him I
think they say like if you Google it
says his salary is 35 million imagine
how much Fox needs to make off of his
show in order to pay him 35 million
dollars a year and run Fox yeah yeah
that's kind of crazy though I mean
I don't I don't understand how they pay
I think what Hannity gets like 60
million or some other ridiculous number
Hannity was getting paid more than
Tucker Oh yeah
it does have seniority but I imagine
Tucker's a much bigger but that wasn't
bringing in a lot of advertising money
because ah that makes sense they all
boycotted him yes well according to the
same website handy was getting the
comparable salary hmm
good yeah he was getting 34 million plus
a 5 million bonus I don't I I don't
think he should make more than Tucker
are you kidding me absolutely not yeah
but I don't trust these websites
celebrity net worth as a salary is 45
million I read somewhere that he was
getting 60 million this one says he gets
25 million these websites are all fake
other people doing these like End Zone
dances about Tucker being fired from Fox
like didn't we just go through this a
couple years ago when Barry Weiss would
left the New York Times and the same
people were doing the same End Zone
dances and then she went on to create
the Free Press which is like dwarfs any
oh it's probably so rich now absolutely
I mean I think she already comes from
like a well-life family and now the rich
have gotten richer because the New York
Times decided to unleash her yeah
exactly so imagine Tucker Carlson he's
gonna like 10x that right you got to
make a video you got to make a cartoon
about like Tucker Scrooge McDuck
swimming and just getting a bunch of
money look I hope that's what happens I
appreciate the optimism I'm seeing from
a lot of conservatives on this part of
my concern is you know I voiced this
yesterday is that because Fox tells
people what is acceptable it was great
to have Tucker there to help shift that
Overton window and introduce a new
audience to ideas that the rest of us
are familiar with or have been reading
up about online but that that audience
wouldn't give credibility to seeing it
on the internet as opposed to cable
television I certainly have no doubt
that Tucker Carlson is going to be
extremely successful it's going to be
fine it's a question of is his message
going to spread as far and wide I hope
so I'm not saying it won't I'm just
saying that having that platform was
definitely very good for America having
someone on cable television saying the
things Tucker was saying was very good
for America I think they also had to pay
out his contract
meaning if he was getting like they
can't just sever his contract so I
imagine they went to him and said we're
terminating your show and he was like
then you owe me 30 million dollars for
the rest of the year and they went okay
it had cut them mature apparently they
they he found out 10 minutes before they
made the announcement so they had to
have just paid him right because you
unless they unless they're like this is
the crazy thing about these contracts
with these big with these big networks
is they they give themselves like
morality Clauses to terminate you in
violation of what the contract is
supposed to do it's like hey we're gonna
hire for three years we're gonna pay you
x amount of dollars for three years then
buried in it says we can fire you for
this specific reason then they just wait
until they can justify whatever that
reason is and then you're gone and they
don't pay you for it but I imagine
they're paying Tucker
I imagine they just wrote a big fat
eight-figure paycheck Tucker girls on
and uh he doesn't have to work what's he
gonna do he's also is it it's Tucker
Carlson like the heir to like the the oh
Henry candy bar fortune or something he
he married into the TV dinner
Fortune oh he's he's in so his wife is
the air heiress to Swanson TV dinners
something like that yeah the Henry thing
that was a Seinfeld reference wow yeah
did he have but you're not old enough to
understand the sign of course only 90s
kids remember that's right is that what
you're talking about some kind of
prominent family himself I'm not sure I
don't know uh yeah the the Vanderbilts
oh wait that's Anderson Cooper oh
oh snap and then he got a summer
internship at the CIA which he abruptly
left and then went to uh I think Iraq to
report on the Iraq War and then got a
job working for the uh for CNN Anderson
Cooper had a CIA I think a two-year I
think it was for two years summer
internship
do you ever leave the CIA no you don't
all right well there you go I was
hanging out with Luke radkowski once and
we were in I think we were in Atlanta or
something and then he saw Anderson
Cooper and he ran up and he was like
Anderson Anderson
you work for the CIA and then I was like
Luke how would I you I what are you
doing like what does that accomplish and
Anderson was just like what are you
talking about and like walked off
because the saying is once CIA always
CIA you know yeah
I mean I think the way it works is that
you're not you might not be on the
payroll but you're an asset right
there's like there's informal
relationships you might not even realize
you're an asset but you've got
relationships they cultivate
relationships in you then you know they
maintain those relationships well I want
to ask the audience here we have this
other story from post millennial
subscribers ditch Fox Nation or guitar
girls Tucker Carlson leaves Network
quote just canceled my Fox Nation
subscription no point in having it
without Tucker Carlson Originals is
anybody who watches this show subscribed
to Fox Nation I did see comments in the
or I saw people chatting and like I
canceled my Fox Nation subscription so
there was some overlap
yeah maybe not anymore maybe they'll I
don't know I'm just kind of thinking
like why is all this happening at once
ABC News fire eight the Disney fired
Nate silver uh BuzzFeed news shut down
yeah Don lemon's fired Tucker Carlson's
out it's there's like some coordinated
things is a global conspiracy are they
trying to turn the frogs gay or
something probably yeah that's got to be
behind it at some point I mean I don't
exactly know how it twists and turns to
get us to that point but I think that's
a safe bet
I mean isn't this just kind of a
reckoning like like these I mean both
the Legacy Media and these New upstart
Media Outlets that came out around like
2013 or so you know your vices and your
buzzfeeds and stuff I mean the Legacy
Media has been on the deathbed for a
long time and those new those new Jack
ones have too I mean they've been like
maybe they had a little bit of lead time
over the over the cable news channels
but like I mean Does anybody read
BuzzFeed news like does anything yes
where I get all of my information
BuzzFeed news you spoke with somebody
earlier today who expressed some
concerns of well they know a lot of
people like within the Republican
establishment who are sort of expressing
some some concerns over whether or not
the audience that Tucker had on on Fox
is actually going to follow him to a
smaller Network or an independent
Network or any of his next project so
maybe they're just sort of trying to
take him off the board again ahead of
the 2024 election he's too big of a
figure to cancel completely but the
thinking is that some of the people who
watched him on Fox May not follow him to
any other platform and get the
information that he was putting out
that's my yeah that's my my fear and
that's basically what I was saying but
you know basically I think the basic
conversation is that um Brian Kilmeade
is going to be a much more based a
version of Tucker Carlson you know
everyone thinks Brian Kilmeade is uh is
the new Tucker yeah that's what I keep
hearing the kids say on twitter.com it's
actually I I guess it doesn't work it's
not funny because no one knows who Brian
Kilmeade is but right yeah he's not
talking about Jesse Waters was the
number two show right yeah I mean why
don't they put Jesse in that slot yeah
yeah does anybody have a reason I don't
know I couldn't tell you why they should
or shouldn't they should uh just not put
anyone in that slot and just put dead
air exactly it just and now a moment of
silence for the next hour for the next
hour and in memory of Tucker Carlson and
then it just shows black and white
pictures of him with sad piano music
playing like Tucker Carlson year of
birth to 2023 so that that's what
they're gonna do to convince the
audience like that he's dead don't
follow him anywhere
we never said he was dead you can't take
us to court but they just mislead the
audience into thinking he's dead so that
they can effectively cancel him so I
guess the we have this video from
ocasio-cortez I'll play for you I'm
sorry that I have to do this to you but
we'll play it anyway
is there no sound out at Fox News here
we go Tucker Carlson is out at Fox News
couldn't have happened to a better guy
um
what I will say though is
while I'm very glad that the person that
is arguably responsible for the
some of the largest driving some of the
most amounts of death threats and
violent threats not just to my office
but to plenty of people across the
country
um I also kind of feel like
I'm like waiting for the cut scene at
the end of a Marvel movie after all the
credits have rolled wow and then you see
like the villains like hand oh my gosh
re-emerge out to glip grip over like the
end of a building or something
but
deep platforming Works no it is
important remember when Captain America
D platform the red School in Marvel just
like Marvel you guys it's like Defenders
a giant corrupt corporation fired him
for speaking out against corporations
and corporate
superheroes bro oh my goodness what I
found fascinating about this is that
she's celebrating an anti-war
personality yes being removed from a
major corporate Network
and she doesn't care at all about
Hannity or Laura Ingram or any other
other personalities that's something
you'd think she'd be able to see okay
Tucker does have right wing politics and
that's bad and scary but you know what
everyone else on Fox does as well and
Tucker is also anti-war and he speaks
out against corporate greed but she is
on the side of a lot of the corporations
that he speaks out against so it's not
convenient and I don't really think
she's all there who are we dealing with
here had that famous moment where he was
doing the handoff with Hannity and he
was complaining about Amazon exploiting
its workers or something like yes and
him and Hannity argued he's like well
some people like the free market Tucker
he's like oh no but yeah and he talks
more like this some people want a good
product from Amazon they're allowed to
buy it and Tucker goes
for those that are just listening I made
a face there's like excuse me idiot says
what he's like what and he's like he
just said he's an idiot you heard it
America and then he goes Tucker you said
what in order to say that I was saying
what and then Tucker was like oops and
then that's that's a Tucker like it was
like
screwed it out but in all seriousness so
I think that was a moment where I was
fairly obvious
Tucker was Tucker was getting the views
and they liked it but he was at odds
with their with the GOP machine I wonder
if this play is more so because they
want to get away from Trump and away
from Maga um like people were saying
it's clearly about the Dominion lawsuit
it's like well Hannity and other
personalities we're talking a lot about
the same thing too and Tucker actually
was rejecting the the the 2020 narrative
from Trump yeah and he got attacked for
it by by uh Trump supporters that's what
I'm so confused about like like if it
was about the if it was about the
election and
why would they not have gotten rid of
Maria Bartiromo and yeah she was way
more into that yeah could he just be the
first Domino
um I mean it would be Domino I gotta be
honest it would be like the coolest
thing ever if like within the next two
weeks every single Fox personality is
fired except Sean Hannity he's the only
guy there all 24 hours he's like I'm not
sleepy anymore now he knows how the
Amazon workers feel he's never sleeping
and he's like maybe there should be
labor laws or something I don't know
it's crazy maybe I need a union or
something today's 24-hour cycle is
brought to you by modafinil do you guys
know I'm a definite no it's what uh
snipers and astronauts take it's a pill
that makes you know kind of sleep oh my
gosh I took it for it's like a
narcolepsy drug in the 60s in France I
took that out from a Grandeur actually
yeah yeah and uh I think the brand name
is pro vigil or something and apparently
you don't got to sleep if you take it
how many times can you take it before
you die I honestly don't know like I
don't know enough about it but like
truckers do it illegally or something
but like it's astronauts and snipers
actually use it and you just stay awake
wow wow yeah I don't know Serge do you
know how long you can take it before
dying uh it's not that nice to take it
doesn't have like abuse potential it
makes you feel like terrible like your
skin gets super dry so I wouldn't you
know it's not a party drug it's not like
Adderall or anything like that but uh
yeah not like not like meth um I don't
know okay I don't imagine I take that
much you'd probably die pretty quick
actually it's very strong wow good to
know yeah so what what what is it it's
like not for people who can't sleep
properly they have narcolepsy or
whatever uh yeah if you have an
narcolepsy it just oh it keeps you awake
during the daytime so you don't fall
asleep while you're taking it basically
um I don't know what it sucks well
ladies and gentlemen
ocasio-cortez was celebrating the
departure of Tucker Carlson but one
other institution was also celebrating
the Pentagon from Politico good riddance
Pentagon officials cheer Tucker
Carlson's ouster it's just like Avengers
it's just so much like the Avengers
movies that I like hey guys this is like
those movies I saw once about the
superheroes
which one uh were they avenge uh no the
boys where homelanders oh my gosh and he
kills a protester and they cheer for it
I know I saw that you didn't see the
boys I got spoiler I guess yeah dude you
ruined it uh I really recommend the show
because it's hilarious but it's very
obvious that so it's basically like
Justice League Batman Superman Etc but
they make the characters flawed or
something like that and homelander
basically Superman is Trump and so he
has rallies and stuff like that he's
political and it's like the show didn't
start this way but the crazy thing is
I'm pretty sure the character Stormfront
a literal Nazi is Laura Loomer oh we
talked about it but I'm not but I'm not
exaggerating like I think they actually
tried getting a character who looked
like her and made the character
Stormfront and then were trying to like
basically I don't think the show was
directly making a statement about Laura
Loomer I think they were inspired by I
mean he doesn't look like her the
character Stormfront she's hot but the
character looks like Laura Loomer the
character Stormfront like similar statue
actress yeah yeah yeah so I and then
they said I think now we have we have uh
like the reporting is they actually uh
were trying to base homelander off Trump
but here's the thing in the show
homelander at the end of last season is
like he's got a song with him and he's
at a rally and then some liberal throws
a water bottle hits his kid and then
homelander just laser beams him and
blows him up or whatever and then
everyone cheers for it and I'm like I'm
fairly certain that if Donald Trump did
do something like that people would not
be cheering sorry it's just not reality
I could shoot someone on Fifth Avenue
but like if if Donald Trump did go on a
Fifth Avenue with a gun and shot
somebody Trump supporters would be like
what happened why did this happen if
Donald Trump went on a murderous Rampage
people people would be like yo I don't
know about all that but like the way the
Liberals view it is they make this TV
show where Trump is basically Superman
which is also a weird insinuation to
make like they think Trump is literally
Superman and they don't like it and then
he kills a guy and they think Trump
supporters are like Yay they live in a
very very strange scary world but anyway
before uh Sheamus got excited about
superhero the point is in an interview
AOC was asked about if America is
heading for another civil war and she's
like well there's a part of History
that's similar to this Captain America
when him and Iron Man fought and I'm
sorry I'm not gonna let go of this this
is ridiculous elected leaders
referencing Marvel movies it's our
common language now this is the state
religion it's a bizarre pop cultural
polytheism and they look to these
superheroes like it's their Pantheon of
gods and it's extremely embarrassing and
pathetic like they're Pantheon it is
well so the story is the Pentagon is
also there with AOC and my point was AOC
was supposed to be this Insurgent
character who was coming into the
Democrat Party and being like I am here
for young people and we don't like the
machine and now she's like Pentagon
we're in this together
so you know yeah they're on the same
team it's it's Captain America we came
together to be to be fair Captain
America was a DOD project
yeah the US government no that is true
no I know that's that's what I'm saying
that's what I'm saying that's how it
gets into their heads right
it's very industrial military complex
you're right no but here's a fun fact
you know so before uh World War II
superheroes usually just kind of like
solved problems in their own communities
in the comics like they would beat
someone up who was doing bad things in
their cities and then it was during
World War II that they started making
all the comics about like the
superheroes saving the world hmm yeah so
the industrial military complex changed
their Universe
I don't know if I'm not saying it was a
concerted effort by the military
industrial military industrial complex
whatever we want to call it today Tim uh
my point is just that the the
um
war effort changed the way that people
saw superheroes which I find interesting
yeah and they're they're an inch they're
a convenient propaganda tool which is
now we're in love with them again they
have um it was trending I guess RT
offered Tucker a job wow
yeah you should take it well you mean
like within the last day
yeah I think that was the reporting let
me pull it up
and the left was like this proves it
let's check it out
Tucker Carlson offered jobs at uh okay
let's get out here with this stupid
video Tucker Carlson is out at Fox News
but welcome on Russian TV the ousted
anchor was offered work by the state-run
news channel in Moscow that Echo much of
his conspiratorial rhetoric on the
Warrington wait what's the byline on
this
that dude once made up a fake story
about me what yeah yeah he made up a
fake story I can't remember exactly what
it was and then the Today Show ran it
what was it it was um
I can't remember the exact story but
they included somebody some leftist
activist this is my understanding what
happened made a super you know you know
they have those activists who will take
clips of you and then mash them together
to make it seem like you said something
different but they're meant to be
humorous so be like a weird colors like
someone made a video accusing me of
saying a thing that was like out of
context and combined with other things
and then he ran the story and then it
got picked up by a bunch of other
outlets that ran it saying like hey you
can't get mad at us NBC News reported it
NBC news then removed the citation so
there's it created a dead citation so a
bunch of other media Outlets were all
referencing each other referencing
something with no Source that's how they
play that that's how they play Ben
Collins wrote a piece I wish I could
remember which piece it was it was
something about you know Russian
disinformation and Bots that in the
Twitter files this Michael
schellenberger found found the email
where they're like in the like Joel Roth
the head of trust and safety is calling
on this story about Ben Collins
like in the emails he's like this is
fraudulent this is there's nothing here
this is complete propaganda uh that was
bad call and story because he hasn't
retracted it yet well I'm looking
forward to the rest of the meeting
collapsing yeah
yeah I was thinking about potatoes I
think by the time you had a potato on
the show while I was gone and put my
name on the title that was great potato
on the show I'm sure it's funny because
we did that they literally did that to
me they're bad friends yeah we put a
potato in that chair and then we put we
put Sheamus in the title card and put a
picture of the potato I mean it's
hilarious I am curious about this though
right so what happens from here let's
say all of traditional media collapses
ooh I mean does the government and the
Deep State and the corporate world all
give up and go I guess we lost I mean
we'll just they'll infiltrate social
media because big Tech already leans in
their Direction like Scrolls the
shape-shifting aliens from the Marvel
that's exactly yes thank you so much I
mean that's exactly what I was thinking
they already have that apparatus
constructed yeah social media that's
what we've been reporting on and with
the censorship industrial complex I mean
they've got every platform basically
except for Twitter at this point because
of Elon musk's take over so like yeah if
it reverts to social media it's not a
problem for them but but let me but let
me ask you about this is Elon being like
do you have free reign are you able to
just access the files or is Elon like
dripping them out to you and giving you
selective information definitely not the
latter we what how how it worked was we
would go in there and then we would ask
for searches so we'd say do a search on
you know this is an enormous Trove of
files um so every email every slack
message so we'd have to say let's I want
to see the emails from all the emails
from Vijaya Gaddy between this date and
this date you know say a five-day span
or something and then they would go and
run the search they would go to another
room and run the search and the reason
why they were doing the stuff in another
room is because they were extremely
paranoid about our seeing any user data
because that's a serious liability for
Twitter so they had to do everything
they could just make absolutely sure
that what we were getting back was just
internal stuff nothing with user data
and then when they would come back with
thousands of emails thousands of slack
messages depending on what we're asking
for and then we'd spend days going
through going through them so there was
no way for I've heard the accusations
that they were like cherry picking this
stuff well I like what they're doing but
I think Elon needs to hire an internal
liaison basically they need to hire you
directly for Twitter so that you as an
employee are able to see user data then
you can choose to what to search for
without limitation it's it's very very
difficult to know what you don't know
it's impossible to to to to know what to
look for if you don't know what exists
yeah and so a good component about going
through these documents is going to be
just sifting through at random raw data
and then finding threads but without
being able to access that system and
peruse it you don't know what to search
for so you're you so what's happening
now is with the Twitter files is I think
you guys are scratching the surface yeah
a lot of the information is damning but
it's what we expect what about searching
for some something that no one thought
to search for you know what I mean I
wouldn't know that's the challenge so
like this is this also also the issue
with the hunter Biden laptop people
don't know what to look for so they've
just it took them a year to find certain
stories we had stories from uh the daily
mail coming out exclusive Hunter Biden
laptop reveals you know Joe Biden was
involved in this deal like a year after
the laptop came out because you have to
go through you know 50 000 emails and
you and then you have to find the
context so there might be an email being
like hey I confirmed that meeting with
the big guy you asked about then you you
can't search for Joe Biden doing deals
you can't search for a corruption you
can't search you can search for the big
guy then you can find Nemo being like
Hey we're on for tonight at 10 pm see
you there and then you're like who's
this guy what is he doing if you went to
someone with a laptop and said search
for Joe Biden in the emails you wouldn't
find that one but that one combined with
another one proves he was involved in
certain business dealings which is you
know news that came out a year later
right so this is the challenge with the
censorship stuff because it's probably
worse than we realize how do we search
through this stuff so you go to them
with search criteria how do you know
that what you're getting back is the
complete picture how do you know what's
all the information that's available
when they hand you a little dossier of
let's say 2 000 documents how do you
know it's not three or four thousand
well so first of all it's important to
know that like Elon when we came into
the Twitter files Elon Musk had just
taken over the company he didn't know
what was in these emails you know he
hadn't he hadn't been there the people
running the searches were brought were
people who were brought in from Tesla
and SpaceX because he'd fired half the
staff of Twitter and later on he fired
some more and he replaced them with
people from his other companies and so
they had no idea like they were like
trying to hold this company together
with duct tape and bubble gum while
running these very time intensive
searches for us they didn't actually
want to be helping us they wanted to be
doing their regular jobs but this was
kind of a task to them
um so so first of all like nobody knew
what was in there before we saw it
um I mean maybe some Old Guard Twitter
people but all these folks were new
which were just as fresh to this as we
were
um and then it would be obvious if there
was stuff missing because we would see
email threads that would just suddenly
end but you know did you actually see
that no we saw no evidence of anything
missing like we like you would expect to
see email threads starting with no with
nothing like out of the blue anymore
is Elon still giving you access to all
the files not at the present moment but
we hope to be back in why not uh I don't
know I mean he's Elon right but like
he's like okay guys no more searching
have a nice day no it was more like we
did our searches we did our reporting
um where we hope to be to have an
opportunity to go back in that would
obviously be at his his invitation we
can't go in there without him
um and uh but that's not at this
particular moment like we hope to be
back in did you ask uh to search for
Alex Jones
we did not do that search that's an
interesting one to do but that's that's
also part of my point like without being
able to just get free reign so much is
limited and the Alex Jones thing could
prove collusion between the networks at
the same time yeah I mean we did have
free reign while we were in there and we
hope to be back in there but to your
point yeah we would need to be I mean I
mean like here's a hard drive start
digging you didn't have that well no but
I don't understand why yeah I mean first
of all because of the user data thing
um and I don't think they can just
separate that also this is a massive
amount of data it's like we're running
searches on it's all the emails all the
slack messages at Twitter for years you
know this is like it's not like you can
just put it on an external hard drive so
the the the the Alex so this this is
this is one of the issues I took with uh
I don't I don't blame Elon Musk for his
selection and journalists I think he
actually did a really good job of
choosing some people to bring on to go
through this it's the best he could have
done but there's probably a lot of
people who should have been given yeah
it was it was too
um I feel like the people he chose to go
through this are in a similar political
that's true also it's important to point
out that he did not choose everybody who
went in there he chose basically he
reached out to Barry and Matt taibi and
then Barry brought in Michael
schellenberger Michael brought me in I
brought Lee fong in
um Matt had a team that he brought in so
he basically invited two people and then
they picked the rest of the people so
this this hand-picked journalist he's
like mad at Matt and Barry Now isn't he
he's not mad at Barry anymore oh okay
that's good he's cool with Barry he's uh
there was a little flap but it was just
over her like tweeting something
critical about his like picking on that
employee or something it was just
nothing
um uh Matt yeah he's Matt's not Matt and
well this has all been reported out I'm
not right right but yeah I think
probably one of the most important
searches after federal government
involvement is Alex Jones because that
looked like a Cascade uh it looked like
a conspiracy to to take one man off of
all of these different platforms I also
wonder if Elon would be like no you
can't search that one because he was
he's like he's out right side he won't
let Alex back on the platform right well
if he did then we would report that out
that he refused to is there anything
that you haven't been allowed to no
correctly nothing except for now that
axis is basically shut off yeah but it's
it's not no it's not shut off it's not
so much it's not like he said you can't
come back in it's just like we had our
time we did our reporting and then we
have to be kind of
like invited back in you know it's not
like we can't just walk in there we
don't have like passes that we can just
use any time of the day
um so you know it's I don't think we've
been shut out it's just I think we'll be
back in there is what I'll say
but you know speaking of conspiracies
like
this stuff the hunter button laptop
stuff it was just reported that that the
origin of the uh of the Russian disinfo
meme came from the Biden campaign and
this has been reported by like two
outlets like it's like this is a huge
story that spells out a literal psyop
like that like it's like all we put all
these pieces together about how the
hunter button laptops um story was you
know the FBI had the computer they had
subpoenaed it there was a receipt that
those were both published in the New
York Post uh we knew so the FBI
definitely had the computer and yet they
were running around to these platforms
saying we think that there's going to be
a uh what appears to be a Russian Hack
and leak dump in a couple of days this
is just like within Days of the New York
Post story breaking going to the to the
platforms and warning them of a of a
hack for information that they knew to
be true assuming that they were talking
about the hunter buying laptop which
seems like it'd be a big coincidence if
they didn't then meantime in the
meantime
um the there was a the Atlanta Council
had organized like a a tabletop exercise
a few weeks before the story dropped
where they invited like National
Security reporters from The New York
Times all these bigwigs to to run a a
tabletop exercise what would happen if
there was a Russian Hack and leak
operation intended to affect the
election involving Hunter Biden and then
they were all gamed out well we would
suppress that and we would like to call
it disinformation so all this stuff was
already like and this has all been
documented and it looked like a big you
know big conspiracy in psyop and then we
find out because Jim Jordan released
this this this letter that it was that
Tony blinken had called Michael Morrell
the acting director of the Sea of the
former acting director of the CIA and
and and
um and didn't ask for but said you know
we're very concerned about this New York
Post story and then Michael Morrell went
on to organize that all those
Intelligence Officers who signed that
letter saying that this has all the
Hallmarks of Russian disinformation
which kicked off the entire thing of
discrediting the story and it and it was
at the past of the Biden campaign and
this has now been reported verified
nobody's talking about this yeah we so
we actually covered that on my podcast
yesterday and it's so insane that
somebody from a presidential campaign
could reach out to Connections in our
intelligence agencies to get them to
fabricate a letter with the names of 50
different intelligence officials on it
saying that this is Russian
disinformation so now you have the added
element of them blaming a foreign power
for something which is unbelievably
irresponsible so that they can try to
get their candidate elected and Trump is
indicted because his campaign supposedly
you know paid off Stormy Daniels at his
behest and they should have disclosed
that like that's a greater example of
corruption than the Deep State operating
at the behest of a member of a
presidential campaign take a look at
this we got the story from spiked and I
always love to uh give you guys the news
guard certification 100 out of 100
that's right it is newsguard certified
and people are like that's the
government so the government certified
it would call whatever you want Joe
Biden's Sinister disinformation campaign
they say last week it was revealed that
shortly before the 2020 election Joe
Biden's presidential campaign conspired
with 51 former spies to discredit the
New York Post discoveries in the hunter
Biden laptop that is to say a person
running for office conspired with
government officials
to discredit a news story that could
harm their campaign and by the way when
Michael Morrell was asked under oath uh
why he did it he said it was because he
wanted Joe Biden to be elected he just
straight up said that
because you can get away with it right
it's a two-tier system yeah
they let you when you're famous
oh my gosh
so uh
well there you go does this mean that
the country doesn't exist or something
it means it's not our country anymore
yeah it's like being worn as a skin suit
by a cult
creepy corrupt individuals just doing
whatever they want we're sitting here
watching how you doing
yeah I'm I'm doing all right with it you
know I'm doing all right
obviously you know talk about this a bit
my hope is is not in this world I think
we could still win this battle though no
I think we're winning I think I think it
simply comes down to uh the reason
they're going after kids so much is
because they know that if they don't
they're done
20 years from now all these conservative
kids are going to be like I vote against
you and they're not going to have kids
because you know they sterilize and
abort them so
you know but also the thing is if they
do go after the kids and really
normalize pedophilias they're clearly
starting to do and gearing up to do then
there's no way for us to win like we've
once that is taken from you once they
win that there's nothing I I I I just
disagree I mean there's too much
required to get to that point where a
conservative can't just move to the
middle of nowhere and keep their kids
away from this stuff
yeah but the fact that you'd have to
move to the middle of nowhere to get
away from people trying to abuse your
kids means you have lost the society you
actually can't do that now because now
California and I forget what other state
but another state as well have passed
law Washington was it Washington was
this are you talking about the um the
um Sanctuary thing the so they passed
they pass lost that if you're if you're
in a marital dispute over your child
transitioning one parent can take that
child and go to California and then
um and then the other and then that
court that case will be adjudicated in
California not in the state of the other
parents so basically you can kidnap your
kid and then there was another law that
was passed in California
um that was I can't remember it past or
if it's set to be passed but that's
basically instructing judges that when
they hear these kinds of cases
essentially telling them to lean in
favor of transitioning being in the
welfare of the child so in other words
you can move to wherever you want to but
if you're in the U.S and you have a
dispute with your with your spouse over
this your spouse can just take your kid
to California so far
and there was also something else I saw
the other day about I I'd have to pull
up the state again but they just passed
legislation saying that these shelters
don't have to report runaways to their
parent if they're identify as trans and
that's why they've run away your kid can
check into a residential rehab facility
without the consent of their parents it
just takes like a social worker or a
psychologist saying yeah I think that
this isn't the kid's best and undergo
abortion services and also gender
transition hormone therapy I don't know
if surgery is included but some hormone
sex change procedures are without the
consent of either parent yeah well and
this is the new paradigm right
historically our understanding was
parents have the final say over what
happens to their child and if the
government is going to get involved they
need to prove that they have a very good
reason they need to demonstrate that
this child is being abused to the point
where the state has to step in now it's
the exact opposite the state has the
final say over what your kid gets to do
the parent has to prove that they should
have their concerns heard about their
own child the law law in California that
is just referred to actually the the law
was they took the existing statute which
said that a kid can check into a
residential rehab facility if number one
a psychologist or social worker
something recommends it and number two
that that kid has been abused or a
victim of incest in the household in
those cases the prior law was in those
cases that kid could go to residential
rehab facility without the parents
consent that's a good law that makes
sense right the new law just struck out
the part about abuse or victim of incest
well they're going to say the parents of
the abusers for not willing to
transition to kids because it's
projection because it's projection
because the left never says we're not
doing that or what we're doing isn't as
bad as what you think they say you're
doing it we're not abusing these kids
you're abusing these kids
right
so it's state kidnapping yeah that's
basically what it is it's the state is
allowed to kidnap your kid so like I
didn't watch the full video with what
Biden said I'd watch the little segment
where he was talking about you know your
you don't own your kids or whatever so I
I don't want to speak to what what the
context was I don't want to be surprised
both but it is sort of like in the
context of these laws that are being
passed I feel like like in the I tweeted
about this like 20 years ago the
religious right used to talk about how
the left wanted to destroy the nuclear
family and at the time I thought that
was ridiculous and Hyperbole and it
probably was ridiculous and hyperbole at
the time
but now it's like it's hard to it's like
well that's actually what these laws
amount to they're saying that the
parents shouldn't have doesn't need to
give consent that that the biggest
threats to the children come from the
parents and that the state and
psychologists and social workers need to
take custody of that kid to protect them
from their parents Sanctuary States now
for sex change surgeries yep what did
Joe Biden just say today Seamus he said
that you don't basically that you don't
own your child the nation does it's like
it's not your kid it's not someone
else's kid it's the nation's kid to
paraphrase what a creep yeah it's
extremely creepy yeah I get to sniff you
can't tell me not to sniff their hair
man
we're gonna get those hairs in my
nostrils
um but I I think to what you're saying
that it's probably true that your your
average liberal person 20 years ago
wasn't going about the Revolutionary
change that they were trying to in state
by saying I want to destroy the family
but all of the intellectual thought
leaders of the left going back decades
did openly say that that was their goal
true I mean yeah the the radical Fringe
of the left
um was definitely saying those things
like the the nuclear family is an
oppressive structure blah blah blah blah
you know and who cares right because
there's a radical Fringe on the left
there's a radical fridge on the right
and they're all crazy and we can just
like ignore them for the most part that
used to be the case and now I mean so
that's the difference right it was like
normal Normie liberals deaf and it's
Remains the case that normally liberals
don't want to destroy the nuclear family
but we are in a situation in which those
radical Fringe activists now are can't
be ignored anymore because they
literally they they they have power over
state legislators and they have power
over you know Federal legislators
arguably but certainly state legislators
in California so now this stuff is
becoming law and it's going to spread
because they're what's happening on the
left right now too is they're working
with younger people to get them elected
into these offices uh Moms Demand Action
some of the anti-gun organizations are
working with 18 to 24 year olds to teach
them and train them how to get into
these positions so they can start
changing the law from the inside and
expanding that agenda yeah
welcome to the new country I guess I'm
still confident that uh we're gonna win
though
I just I I just think it's math we can
talk about all the things they want to
do to kids and how they want to create
these Sanctuary States but the reality
is if you keep your kids away from this
this cultural influence they've lost so
I think part of what you're saying is
that when people do the right thing and
have good ideas and behave virtuously in
the long run they win because people are
doing bad things in behaving in vicious
ways end up eating themselves alive and
their society collapses but if the rot
spreads so far within your culture that
it completely usurps it well then your
entire civilization collapses before
that good can eventually win out once
people try to rebuild From the Ashes and
I'm not saying that that's a guarantee
here what I am saying is I agree with
you that in the long run good wins but
that doesn't mean America is still
around 100 years from now America will
be around it just won't be the same and
I'm not saying that there won't be a
collapse a long fall or a civil war or
whatever I'm just I know you're not
saying there won't be a civil war yeah
the right's gonna win
it's basically it's it there's like
historical precedence very rarely do the
the I mean let's put it this way the
left are they aren't anti-gun Liberals
are anti-gun yeah the left likes guns
but you still can't compare compare a
soy boy to like a military veteran and
the left likes to show these big fat
militia guys and they're like haha like
that guy could go toe-to-toe with the
national Guardsman and it's like dude
the National Guard will be split the
same as any other part part of this
country and I got I gotta I got news for
these guys the big fat militia guy
probably is still better trained with a
gun than a soy boy and someone like left
us an antifa guy the left has the John
Brown gun club and like a bunch of these
you know was it the Socialist Rifle
Association or whatever and those guys
are probably a lot better with weapons
but that big fat militia guy is going to
be better than the average
thin scrawny vegan soy boy dude I mean
isn't it really hyper polarizing though
to see these two distinct these distinct
individuals the stereotypes on the right
you have The Stereotype of the morbidly
obese militia guy and on the left you
have the gaunt and frail antifa guy
isn't it kind of weird maybe something
to do with being vegan
no offensive vegans I got no beef I'm
just saying you know a lot of vegans
aren't getting enough protein they don't
got no beef either bro quite literally
no beef no beef
yeah so I I don't know a long story
short
I just don't see how the left can
possibly win if they don't have kids I
mean one thing to pay attention to is
that a lot of the stuff with the Trans
stuff and I want to stipulate this by
saying I do not have a problem with
adults transitioning don't care that's
fine do what you want to it's the the
kids who who concerns me but a lot of
the it's the The Bluest cities in the
blue Estates where a lot of this where
the most affirming is happening both not
just at the medical level but also in
the schools and just in the general
culture so it's parents of kids who are
gender questioning or whatever in those
in in your Brooklyns and in your San
Francisco's who are coming face to face
with the Stark reality of of of how deep
and pervasive this stuff is and they're
getting red pilled like when they see
this happening to their own kid their
kid is questioning they're supportive
right they're like being super
supportive they know the right things to
do but then they go to the the the
therapist is like oh well your kid is
definitely trans and we need to put them
on hormones they're like wait what you
gotta
and they might go further even but then
the kid starts to regret it and then it
becomes this whole mess and then the
parents are studying this stuff along
the way they're they're looking up you
know these are like you know these are
like you know uh upper middle class
laptop class people they're looking up
the medical studies they're reading the
medical studies they're realizing that
there's actually no medical basis to the
claim that that puberty blockers are
reversible they're all that stuff and
then they start to question everything
and then 95 of dysphoric people grow out
of it in puberty right there was a story
about a family who said that they're
they were very leftist very pro-trans
very supportive until one day their son
came out and said he was trans and they
were like what that's no you're not and
so they started talking like to him and
to each other like you have no symptoms
of this you don't show nothing of this
why are why are you saying this when
they brought the kid into counselors and
stuff the counselor said no he no he's
definitely trans and then they said
these things aren't true though
basically like the kid was saying oh
yeah I used to do this I used to do that
I used to do this and the parents were
like no no that's not true yeah and they
were like you're just denying your son's
lived experience and all of these things
and this the family then basically said
we realized a lot of this stuff was
being pushed on our kid who was just
trying to fit in and going along with it
and it was freaky to see the whole
machine pushing in this direction yeah
to make your kidney by the way a huge
proportion of those kids are autistic as
well right they don't know stock stuff
they don't know how to uh to fit in
socially right and so when someone says
this is what's socially acceptable they
disagree right it's easy to blame all
your problems you know your if you were
abused you have trauma whatever
um you have other mental disorders all
this stuff and it's like somebody comes
with you with a solution they're like oh
well all of this is a clear sign of
gender dysphoria and all you have to do
is take this drug and everything will be
okay that's just a very seductive
proposition to the kid who's let's let's
jump to this story actually and then
we'll we'll carry on this conversation
because uh this is this is epic we have
this in the Daily Mail Bud Lights
hangover gets worse rival Coors Light
and Miller Lite sales Spike 18 in Wake
of Dylan mulvani debacle check this out
between April 2nd and April 5 18th
overall volume of sales of Bud Light at
bars and restaurants dropped by 34.7
percent
can I get a holy crap that's massive so
the boycott's certainly working and I
don't know what it is but I mean I I
should I should put it this way I have
an idea of what I think it is I think
what they basically did was they came
out and said that that Bud Light is the
beer for a feminate Millennials and so
all of these you know middle-aged guys
was like I don't drink that I don't
drink Bud Light but like already had a
bad reputation for being like piss water
yeah and but you know who cares if
you're at a bar and you're like I just
want to get drunk but now it's piss
water that's associated with being
effeminate and being you know kind of
uncool they've effectively made their
brand not cool and so now you've got
middle-aged dudes being like I don't I
don't drink that I don't look at me yeah
right I think it's also just like people
don't want this stuff politicized right
it's like the same with the NBA or you
know the whatever it's like people just
like they're like get this give me a
break right let me drink my beer let me
watch my basketball game without being
pushed with a political message whether
whichever side it comes but I think it
definitely comes from one side I think
that only goes so far because we've seen
that with a lot of things video games
people are still willing to play a video
game that gets politicized if they're
like okay fine whatever people are still
willing to watch certain TV shows that
are like moderately woke to a certain
degree as long as it's not that in your
face right but when it comes to beer I
think what they did was they just made
the beer they they got a very effeminate
individual to almost they need to
sponsor it and that's the image
associated with it now yeah well so if
you are a Bud Light Drinker it's you
know it's like does some 40 year old
dude at a ball game want to be seen as
like a dude at a nightclub with a frilly
pink dress probably not yeah you made a
point a moment ago about how people will
watch something on television even
though it's woke because they find it
entertaining part of the difference is
you advertise the things you consume in
terms of food or beverage differently
than you advertise what you see on TV
you can kind of have a TV show that
other people don't know you watch and so
you're watching something a little more
work where people wouldn't expect from
your secrets but if that's the yeah like
if that's the beer you order at the bar
or even if you want to drink that beer
in secret like it's in your fridge dude
reruns of Will and Grace Just that's my
favorite show ever a funny horse it is
funny show but uh yeah you're right out
in public you have to I disavow by the
way I don't watch Tim is once again
smearing me because Luke was in his DMS
crying about the fact that I'm stealing
his Thunder and so I'm competition that
has to be taken out but anyway anyway
what was I I totally lost my train of
thought because you were talking about
potatoes or something I'm sorry that is
see this is like the kind of racism I
have to tolerate every single time I'm
here uh you were talking about the fact
that we were just talking about how
people can hide the media that they
think right when you're out in public
yeah you're drinking a Bud Light you're
making a political statement now do you
think how like I guess I feel like you
have to ask this about every story now
like how much of this stuff has pervaded
regularly oh this has this has yeah for
sure it's not just like I have people
asking me about it when I'm at the
casinos or whatever really like I'm at a
poker table and people are like yeah
what's up with that thing that was weird
I'm not gonna drink that and then there
was one uh where you know they have like
the the lady will come around asking for
drinks and then someone made a crack
like not a Bud Light and then everybody
Chuckles and I'm like man like people
know this well you know it's funny it
used to be that people would be like I
mean people used to ask the question or
I still asked the question that I just
asked which is like is this just for the
terminally online or normie's getting
this and actually we're in an age where
everybody's terminally online so if it's
pervading your bubble it's pervading a
lot of people's bubbles but even so I
mean your average person you don't need
to be terminally online to say why is
this guy in a in a dress and makeup on
my beer and when you talk to a lot of
people at the casino or just in general
I can't speak to your Casino experience
but you ask them how did you feel about
that Bud Light thing or do you support
till Mulvaney you know maybe if they're
more online like we are more into
politics they'll sort of launch into
their explanation of why it's bad for
the culture if your average person just
like no I don't support that one that's
weird I just don't like it they won't
give you right they're not selling those
ones no no not anymore no they were
never selling it right oh and so what
what the left said was oh it's all over
one commemorative can that wasn't for
sale but it's not Dylan Mulvaney had a
video where he had a stack of beer cans
and was smiling and being like look
drink this stuff and then I don't even
know what March Madness is so it's like
you are insulting your your core Market
oh totally and then the VP came out and
she was like we don't like this frat
humor and we want to change our audience
and it's so it's not only so that's the
thing I see I see more than just normal
vanity I see they came out and actually
spat in the face of Their audience and
now the fact that they fight weird I'm
sorry I should say they put two VPS two
Executives on leave from their marketing
team without actually apologizing is
they're probably going to the
shareholders being like don't worry we
got rid of these people but they hate
you their former customer so much they
won't just apologize nobody asked them
to put anybody on leave well I did not
come on the show and say I demand they
remove and fire this woman I said just
say we're sorry for sponsoring Del
Mulvaney we didn't mean to to be
divisive and to upset anybody and they
were like nah we're not going to do that
we're going to quietly remove these
people to save our stock because that's
what really matters and then we're gonna
say nothing to you and hope you just
forget about it yeah I mean they were
looking for a class of consumer that was
higher status in their view you know
frat guys they're they're embodying
toxic masculinity and they're bigoted
there's just all sorts of baggage tied
up with anything with fraternity or
manhood uh and of course Dylan Mulvaney
it's new trendy and supportive of
transgenderism which is the most trendy
thing on the planet right now and those
people are just better than you and
that's why we want their money and not
yours that's right because we here at
Bud Light are better than you and we
know it exactly we need better customers
no they know that they screwed up yeah
but I think I'm at the point where I was
saying this earlier that if they don't
issue a formal apology by this week and
I'm not saying to fire anybody I'm not
saying to write a 500 page Manifesto I'm
saying all right just be like Manifesto
we are we are sorry for sponsoring Dylan
Mulvaney we we hope to retain you as
customers we apologize for for a
divisive ad
you know thank you and have a nice day
I'd be like okay that's it that's fine
that's all that's that's it I think a
lot of people wouldn't though if I think
there is really like a bad taste that's
been left in people's mouths at this
point that's what I'm saying I'm saying
at this point their unwillingness to
actually just be like hey are bad we
didn't mean to to sponsor this person we
know you get pissed off we did not
realize who this person was we won't do
it again their unwillingness to say
anything close to that says to me they
literally don't care about you and they
don't care if they get you back so I'm
like at this point I'm not a Bud Light
guy I'm not an Anheuser guy I actually
really like Modelo but I don't drink a
whole lot but I will I will have no
problem saying I will never forgive the
company if if they've gone this far
without just being like Hey we're sorry
about this so what I would like to say
is I will never buy another Bud Light
again if they don't apologize this week
but I really don't buy Bud Light so it's
kind of meaningless I will say this the
events we're doing we did this in Texas
we pulled all Anheuser products from the
show good for you so anybody who came in
they could not buy it not that anyone
wanted to we were making butter Bud
Light the whole time what do you think
insult is to the consumers exactly is it
that it's kind of that it's kind of a
troll and saying the consumer is
condescending the consumers got mad they
said hey we're upset about this so Bud
Light goes I got an idea let's ignore
them then the boycott persisted over the
holiday week holiday weekend and the
pundits were like whoa this is crazy
conservatives don't normally do this so
then Bud Light was like let's keep
ignoring them then on Friday they came
out and said we don't like to be
divisive thank you
and everyone's like what what is the
statement itself then they put out a
commercial about a horse running through
America and it runs to New York to never
forget 9 11. and it was insulting to do
I started getting Budweiser ads and I'm
like what is this just say sorry so now
what's insulting is they keep doing
these things without apologizing as if
we're too stupid to realize what we're
upset about and instead of apologizing
they put two marketing execs on leave
that only is why just the fears of
shareholders and not customers and now
we're going on to week three without
them saying sorry about that guys
they're clearly at a point where they're
like if we lose this customer base so be
it ethelm
the thing is that while I can understand
why Bud Light drinkers would be insulted
by the by the company Dylan Mulvaney
himself I'm just going to say himself is
um is just this walking insult to half
the population of the country of women
but also it's like and also trans people
absolutely he's a he's a he's a parody
of trans people and he is like he's like
think if you did this he's like a
for women people it's like it's
like is that the right word like he's
just like a character he's like this
this the equivalent of a racist like a
modern day mental show yes absolutely
but but it's and people say it's Woman
face I think Donald Mulvaney is doing
trans face right I think it's I I don't
draw I guess I don't draw a distinction
between the two but no there is there
there is and I know everyone's heard me
say it but I'll explain it just for your
sake Sheamus and for those that may not
have heard it people with gender
dysphoria don't sing about their bulges
to 10 million people they people judges
for I feel anxiety and that's what
gender dysphoria is their their body
gives them anxiety could you imagine an
anorexic person making a video being
like look how fat I am look how fat I am
and squeezing their rolls no that gives
them anxiety they they don't want to be
fat Dylan Mulvaney is the opposite of
what you'd actually expect from a person
suffering from dysphoria singing songs
about his bulge right what he's done is
he's capitalized on the algorithm he's
exploited the left who will support this
to no end to create a mockery of trans
people and women and then get corporate
protection and sponsorship to do it yeah
it's it's really remarkable it's
actually literally a transphobe
I mean I think I don't know if he has
I'm not saying that he has contempt for
Trans people but I'm saying that the
character that he plays is hateful to
trans people right like even if it's not
the intent right like a Minstrel show
and I think he's I mean yeah I think his
intent is he's a theater kid who found a
stick that's making him rich and getting
a lot of attention I don't think it's
any more complicated than that yep you
know and Dylan Mulvaney is not posted
since the controversy started so we're
now going into week three of no posts
from Dylan Mulvaney and I've said this
the other day the people who who are in
Dylan's life family members however need
to give him an intervention and be like
stop this it's going too far you know
there like I mentioned this the other
day they're trans YouTubers pointing out
that Dylan's not doing things typically
associated with being trans doesn't
appear to be taking estrogen doesn't
appear to be getting actual uh
feminization like so Dylan got facial
surgery but people are pointing out not
laser hair removal which is the cheaper
and faster procedure but permanent and
so the insinuation is Dylan expects this
to run its course at some point
absolutely and it'll be on to the next
thing right and then Dylan will just be
a d transitioner yeah or or just you
know whatever yeah
and Budweiser will have made their bed
and their their I I honestly think
there's no way Budweiser gets out of
this they tried doing the Clydesdale
commercial to be like we're patriotic
and we love America but they've already
have become the brand are you telling me
that in addition to the bank industry
failing and the entire media family
they're the brand of Pride parades and
things like that yeah and I don't care
about that but there's going to be a lot
of middle-aged dues dudes who don't want
to be that you know it's like why why do
people dress a certain way why do people
choose to wear certain clothes they want
to portray an image to other people
social acceptance is extremely important
to people so for a Suburban middle class
dad who wants to be seen as a strong man
around his friends who doesn't want to
be seen as weak pathetic and effeminate
he ain't drinking Bud Light anymore
probably never again
the thing I would take issue with the
way you described it before though or
the thing that I think is just a little
bit outdated is that the idea that
you're right that he's
performed his performance is completely
at odds with the idea of somebody with
actual gender dysphoria but the
discourse has moved on to a point where
you don't have to have gender dysphoria
that's not in fact it's considered
insulting yeah some trans activists to
insist that somebody needs to have
gender dysphoria to be trans because
it's become it's gone from a what was
considered a mental disorder to what was
considered just kind of like a condition
that you need that you could be treated
for and healed from to essentially a
lifestyle Choice yes right it's like you
just choose and so Dil milvaney is a
very good portrayal of that just you all
you have to do is announce it well part
of the utility of gender dysphoria for
the transgender movement and that label
is it also did place a pathology on it
that a person could be suffering within
trying to escape whereas the view of
them as Auto gynophilia example which
many of them are who knows how you can
quantify it but which is just a person
who's sexually aroused by the thought of
them being themselves as the opposite
sex is something people are far less
comfortable with because don't forget
the AAP as well the AAP Auto oh yes yes
yes exactly which is the the female
Varian woman who's aroused
conceptualizing himself as a man because
then what you have to admit is that you
are being forced to participate in
someone else's sexual fetish which is a
lot of which is a lot harder to justify
to the public in the short term now in
the long run if they really do continue
to win the culture War and the ways that
they have and we don't keep pushing back
they're eventually just going to start
openly and bidding yes there is Auto
gynophilia and Otto androphilia and
that's okay and you should still be
forced to participate in their fetish
that's what I think the Leah Thomas
controversy was this the NCAA swimmer
the male was apparently posting things
on social media about being was AGP they
call it which is to imply that
this this individual is being excited in
a matter of speaking by forcing other
people to participate in this in this
fantasy wow exactly which is at the very
least something we would have called
sexual harassment several years ago
saying I'm going to go into the women's
locker room and force them to say that
I'm a woman because that gets me off
that's predatory in and of itself it's
not a question of is this person going
to physically assault someone while
they're in there you're already forcing
them to engage in sexual fantasy and
role play with you let's let's do a hard
segue here because I have the story from
timcast.com Georgia D.A puts police in
heightened security amid potential
mid-summer indictment of trump multiple
legal experts believe she will follow
through with criminal charges and uh I
think so but the story was written by
Adrian Norman so I'll throw it to you
what's going on
who uh what's going on is the uh
continuation of the what five-year now
Saga we have of the get Trump Mafia who
are looking at any other way to try to
get this guy and stop him from returning
back to the White House I mean we got
the case in New York
um with uh uh
we've got the special prosecutor in DC
who's after him and now we've got uh you
know Fannie Willison in Georgia and I
think they're trying to throw a bunch of
stuff to the wall and see what sticks
and and the Federal indictment now where
they got his secret service testifying
against them
so we're looking at was it three but
it's probably gonna be more we got at
least three yeah New York Federal and
Georgia they are going to uh indict
Trump and then I guess my question for
the panel is do you think Trump gets
convicted in any of these jurisdictions
the Georgia one is over the I hope like
interference or whatever thing yeah the
2020 election when he was on the phone
with the state officials saying hey can
you find votes so that is a much much
much more serious case than this garbage
in New York absolutely there they're
trying to hit him with Rico charges
right wow yeah yeah it's pretty pretty
serious stuff and again it's uh I mean
if you follow the case at all you know
it's very clear that he wasn't intent on
engaging in any sort of fraud but they
had thought that fraud had occurred
because there were so many anomalies and
problems that occurred in the election
and so many questions that were raised
but obviously you know one of Trump's
greatest flaws and this has been the
case since he ran for office is that
he's very imprecise and he says things
that are allow you to easily
misinterpret what his actual intent is
or intentionally well yeah a lot of
context so you know in his Pursuit for
for what was really a sort of a
righteous cause and saying hey you know
we think that there was a mistake that
was made with a certain number of votes
find out what's true what's not they're
misinterpreting the entire tenant of his
phone call his team's investigation to
frame it as though he was trying to rig
the outcome of the election when he
wasn't he was simply trying to discover
whether or not election frauded actually
but I don't think that that matters I
think they will make up any reason to go
after him the the documents thing New
York New York they're going to convict
him
that I just I do not see a New York jury
acquitting Donald Trump I don't and and
this is going to be in Georgia but it's
probably going to be in a more urban
District I imagine when they bring him
down I don't know how he's gonna what
he's gonna if he's gonna try and uh
you know make some argument for a
separate a different venue in the state
or something that's more favorable which
makes no sense and then you also have
the Eugene Carroll thing where I guess
Trump didn't show up is that what
happened do you guys were you following
that no all I saw was that there were
people were tweeting Trump's a no-show
at the Aging Carol uh case she's
accusing him of rape from like 50 years
ago or something and yup they got it in
the courts I I got this you guys might
not agree with us this might be
unpopular but I do think that he was
looking for votes I mean I do think that
he was trying to to look for
um you know I think he was trying to
pressure
um the state to throw the election to
him
serious case but I mean I don't I don't
I I I will like plead ignorance that
it's not something that I followed very
closely I just know the top lines like
everybody else it just it just
it's just it's well how do you find
votes what does it even mean like in the
worst possible I don't know that he had
a specific plan for what he was trying
to ask of them I think he was just
trying to exert his influence and say do
what you need to do you're the secretary
of state do what you need to do to you
know do what you need to do and I don't
wanna I don't want to know what it is is
basically what are you saying but you're
going to find the votes to deliver
George to me that's what I think he was
trying to communicate
but you reported this out I mean we have
the uh we have the full transcript of of
the call so we know exactly what was
said and again it's one of those things
where Trump is Trump he says some things
that oftentimes can be misinterpreted
and I think that's what happened and you
have liberal media establishments that
run with these narratives and the truth
makes it around the world before the
excuse me the live mix around the world
before the truth has boots on and I
think there were so many stories that
were being pushed through the mainstream
media
um regarding this particular story that
framed it in a certain way it didn't
even matter what the truth was at that
point yeah get the transcript up yeah
yeah I'm gonna try and uh see if I can
what is this um Trump says thank you
very much hello Brad and Ryan blah blah
blah we're getting 20 30 25 30 000
people at a rally we have a number of
things we have at least two or three
anywhere from 250 to 300 000 bouts were
dropped mysteriously into the rolls much
of that had to do with Fulton County
which hasn't been checked we think that
if you check the signatures a real check
of the signature is going back to Fulton
County you'll find at least a couple
hundred thousand Forge signatures of
people who have been forged and we are
quite sure that's going to happen but I
mean that is that is just Trump's
speculation he was wanting them to go
and look for it so like in in that
context I'd say this if Trump was like
Hey do a signature verification because
I I bet those are no good signatures is
that trying to swing an election no but
I don't think that he would personally
make that phone call right like the
president of the United States is
calling and saying hey we've got this
report like you would run that through
somebody else if that was seriously your
goal it just seems like a personal phone
call from the president saying this is
fishing I want you to act that was he's
the president you think he's going to
try to swim an election when everything
he's doing is recorded he's in a room
full of advisors but but it's not just
that I mean what he's what he's saying
right here is
if if let's just remove it from Trump if
an individual says I believe there was
impropriety here and I and I think you
should allow us to check for it is is
that above board or or you know the
problem is that like we could you know
this would be like how it would go in a
courtroom where we would be parsing
these words and trying to figure out the
literal meaning and discern the intent
from actual evidence which is how you
should or litigate but like really this
is an exercise just right here in mind
reading right we like we have no idea
but my so it's totally intuitive but so
here's the let me read you the full
quote from Donald Trump and I'll stress
too I think he's wrong about the fraud
narrative
um I do think there's issues with you
know in Time Magazine they wrote The
Shadow campaign you see the article the
shadow campaign to save the election yes
they wrote what they did and how they
did it it was procedural it was through
governor it was with deals over a year
and it was shutting down entertainment
which resulted in a mass amount of
mail-in ballots then I think the
question is
if if if how do I phrase this people are
saying it's fraud when in reality it may
be just like lower standards meaning
ballots came in through through mail-in
voting and they were just like this
one's probably fine as opposed to in the
past they'd be like we're going to
scrutinize the signature so this is what
Trump said
he says um let me see if I have to read
more because well whatever he says
you're going to find that they are which
is totally illegal is more illegal for
for you than it is for them because you
know what they did and you're not
reporting it that's criminal that's a
criminal offense and you count that
happen blah blah blah he says and they
were moving machinery and they're moving
it as fast they can both of which are
criminal fines and you can't let it
happen and you are letting it happen you
know I mean I'm notifying you that
you're letting it happen so look all I
want to do is this I just want to find
11 780 votes which is one more than we
have because we won the state and
flipping the state is a great Testament
to our country because because you know
this is a testament that they can admit
to a mistake or whatever you want to
call it if it was a mistake I don't know
a lot of think a lot of people think it
wasn't a mistake it was much more
criminal than that but it's a big
problem in Georgia and it's not a
problem that's going away I mean you
know it's not a problem that's going
away
so this one snippet in context is Trump
saying I believe there was criminal
action in your state and I want you to
actually have an investigation of it and
they just said no to him and he says
look I'm just saying we need to I want
to find 11 000. the context that I see
there is for one I think Trump pushing
the criminal thing was a was a was was
like a heavy-handed threat claiming
fraud was to try and scare them into
actually doing it but Trump is basically
saying to them
I believe there are ballots with bad
signatures I believe that if you
investigate you will see hundreds of
thousands and I just need to find 11 780
of them to win
I mean it's possible that it's both of
what we're describing because he could
have truly believed that he won the
state and he could have truly believed
that there was fraud but the way he went
about but he but he also was
single-mindedly focused on flipping the
state which he says in the statement and
he's leaning on the Secretary of State
in a very totally inappropriate way
saying get in light of all this
do what you need to do to deliver the
election to me because I deserve it
because I actually want it I mean let's
say there's no there's no reason to get
any more votes than you actually need to
win that's actually a legal standard
so so when it comes to these lawsuits
one of the big things we've we found was
that you can't actually file a lawsuit
unless you can justify just enough votes
to actually have one so
it would there's there's an argument
that suing for a number that it's like
to an extreme degree would be would be
deemed like
um gratuitous it's like if if you file a
lawsuit if you can prove one more vote
then you needed to win you have standing
but but my point is this let me ask you
if if you were involved in a a
competition let's let's call it day an
origami competition and then uh you
folded 1 000 paper cranes and then
notice that a bunch of the paper cranes
on the other side you believed looked
suspicious what's the appropriate way to
going to go about checking to make sure
your opponents were on the level if you
go to the judges and say hey I think
those cranes are fake well by your
standard you're saying that you're
putting undue pressure on the judges to
allow you to win
do I in this situation am I somebody who
has you're the reigning Champion power
over the judges though well as the
reigning champion and the fan favorite
you know right but there's a concern
that if you don't win people are going
to be mad but the but this is he's
leaning on somebody who is in his
political party who's part of the
political apparatus that he's the head
of the but he has no power
the issue I take with your argument is
that if there ever is any impropriety
the only thing you can do is give up and
submit to those I'm not saying that
that's that I'm what I'm saying is that
I think that he was doing something
inappropriate and that he was I think
that his intent was to basically bully
his way into having Georgia deliver to
him I'm not making any like judgments
reading is a bad legal standard that
what you don't think that mind reading
is a bad legal standard but no I'm just
saying my opinion I'm not I'm not a
lawyer I'm not I'm not arguing I'm not
litigating so the issue is you've made a
determination about Georgia you've then
determined that anyone who opposes that
determination is doing something
nefarious you see my point uh uh well
you're trying you're it seems like
you're asking me to take my standard and
apply it as a universal standard and I'm
and I'm not prepared to do that because
what I'm saying is if I don't know and
don't have the evidence of an outcome I
would expect certification and
confirmation
if uh if a woman goes to the police and
says this man committed a crime against
me I would expect the police to actually
do some kind of preliminary
investigation not necessarily condemn
the guy or or charge him or arrest him
but to be like we'll look into it if a
politician goes to the police and says
that their daughter had been brutally
assaulted and raped and the cops were
like well I'm not going to do anything
about it and the guy says look I'm just
asking you to go and investigate the guy
that is not in my opinion undue pressure
to for for a polishing to get some kind
of legal outcome it's literally what
everyone is supposed to do if they feel
something bad happened I think Trump I
don't I don't know what happened in
George I think Trump's fraud narrative
is is wrong I think they explain exactly
how they won with the shadow campaign
changing procedural rules Trump's
argument here is that they were lacks on
voter on voter signature verification
and that if they looked into it they
would probably find hundreds of
thousands I don't know if that's true or
not it's immaterial the issue is they
didn't actually check and the only way
you'd actually seek to rectify a problem
like that is to go to them and say do it
yeah so I my issue is while I disagree
with Trump I don't see any other way to
seek remedy other than asking someone to
do a verification of it well this is
obviously not a hill I'm prepared to die
on but I would say that what you guys
are saying is totally fair
um I think that this is the basis for a
case because like if he if it's as you
say and it's all on the up and up then
that's going to be the defense's
position and if the if but if it is the
case that he was trying to sway the
election inappropriately that's a
serious offense I'm saying that it's a
serious case unlike for example Stormy
Daniels which is totally frivolous but
let me ask you this what if they do go
back and find actually we found twelve
thousand uh mismatched signatures would
that what would you then think Trump was
acting inappropriately if they can it
would definitely it would definitely
change the context of my thinking about
but they didn't actually go back and and
take Trump's request seriously so then
we'll never know but then so how could
you have a negative view if they didn't
do any anything you know what I mean
like if they went back and said Trump
was wrong then I'd agree with you I'd be
like wow Trump was totally wrong so uh
Trump trump Trump's argument here was
mismatched signatures and it's like well
I don't know maybe they didn't chat I
mean the the fraud stuff I certainly
think is wrong that was weird that was
like dominion and stuff and the CIA and
all that was out of the question yeah
but arguing about lack's signature
verification policies something totally
different yeah so your point is since it
didn't amount to anything
then there's no real it's not it's like
well it's it's like look if you have two
people who are standing before a judge
and one saying acts and one saying why
I think it's inappropriate to be like
how dare you ask that question person a
when a judge should be like okay show me
your evidence and then the person will
be like here's a list of things I think
justifies my claim and the judge should
then be like person B do you have a
counter claim to to refute this and then
if investigation is like if there's
probable cause then a court should be
like okay we're going to Grant a
signature verification request to see if
these claims are accurate I mean it's
sort of like okay to take an extreme
example if you were to if you're an
elected official and you went to
somebody and you're like you're like
listen you know
uh it seems like you you might need help
with your daughter's private school
education and like like does that of
interest to you and oh by the way I'm
looking for this particular favor and
you're saying everything's short of you
know directly offering a bribe you could
you could have the same litigation
around whether this was entire maybe he
was just trying to help out or is the
the person's daughter who was going to
private school you know and like like
you it would come down to this mind
reading thing or you could look at the
totality of the circumstances and say
this looks a lot like like a bribe but I
think that situation it's easier to make
a quid pro Crow right because Trump
doesn't say specifically I could do this
thing for you yeah he just said hey I
think this thing happened will you check
and they said no and then he was like
are you kidding me and they're like no
go away right and then your your
attitude is like how dare Trump ask for
for a remedy to a perceived problem if
if someone so there's there's a few
questions around this I mean if we're
dealing with matters of public interest
then I don't think the Fourth Amendment
plays a role if the government is is
involved in something then the
government has a right to publish to the
people the results of a search I don't
see how it makes sense that I'll put it
this way if someone came to me if if
someone did the cops and said you know
Tim Poole stole my Spoons the cops would
be alike we'll we'll talk to him and
we'll see what's going on and then if
they can't get any probable cause to get
a warrant too bad so sad have a nice day
and that's it however if it's a group of
police officers are carrying a bunch of
spoons and then one person says they
stole my spoons and another person says
actually they didn't you're lying and
then a person calls the police chief and
says I I you look just look in the
police locker room and if the spoons are
there that proves it I don't see that as
undoing or like if a politician did it
it doesn't matter if the fact the fact
is we're dealing with an election the
smartest thing in the world to do would
be for Georgia to be like you know what
Trump so that we can throw out all
confusion we absolutely will do the
check and prove to you you're wrong yeah
yeah instead they said we're going to
arrest you and criminally indict you for
daring to ask I'm applying the same
standard that I'm that I would apply to
the situation that we discussed earlier
in which Tony blinken called Michael
Morrell and he said I'm very concerned
about the possibility of Russian Russian
interference in the election around the
hunter Biden laptop story but he never
asked according to morel's testimony he
never said could you write this letter
listen and but Michael Morrell took his
marching orders and like you could say
so Yuri blinker was just concerned about
Russian disinformation but you're
insinuating that Trump was secretly
instructing them to fabricate ballots is
that what you're saying uh I mean this I
don't know I I I'm not sure that he even
had it that well thought out it I think
it's much more crass than that it's just
like
do what you need to do but this is my
priority go do it I I don't want a dog
pile but I just want to make a point uh
about about the analogy I think part of
where it breaks down is with blinken
they all came out and said this was Russ
and Russian disinformation even though
it wasn't right I think that's what
makes that situation different and and
really egregious is they ended up saying
something that wasn't true for a
political campaign
well let's go to super chats because
we're not going to resolve that one but
uh I think we better points
um and then if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button become
a member at timcast.com
click the join us on the website you'll
get access to our Discord server to hang
out with like-minded individuals and
access to the members only uncensored
show which will be on the front page at
about 10 10 p.m but for now we will read
what you all have to say in the super
chats I'm not your buddy guy says it's
sad seeing Heroes who stand up being
crushed whether it's Julian Assange
James O'Keefe Donald Trump or to Carlson
globalism
by the way Luke was in chat saying
Sheamus is a dog and then later a dirty
dog so he's still upset that is deeply
offensive I know all right Goldilocks
production says I deleted Fox News app
unsubbed from them on YouTube and
unfollowed them on Rumble and apple
Newswatch they showed their true colors
this week and Legacy Media can go Fade
to nothing here here good sir
all right sa Federal says Tim Steven
Crowder says Rumble is under DDOS while
they grow you need to get Tucker and
Zero Hedge under that umbrella and pay
at least 20 bucks a month or 40 bucks
for a good option to show the hand of
the market beats communism
yup yup all right what do we got Max
Redick says Tim I know you and Crowder
are friends but we can we put that aside
for a minute to acknowledge that he was
crappy to daily wire and Dave Landau
accuse Candace Owens of extortion and
now he used his divorce as a grift
crappy
I don't know at all what's going on man
earlier there was a video from Crowder
talking about a divorce and insinuating
he played like a clip of Candace Owens
and insinuated he was being extorted or
something then Candace Owen said that
he's accusing her of extortion it's like
dude I ain't got nothing to do with that
nor do I know and the there's there's
I'm you know we talked about the Landau
thing and then I'm hearing other people
comment that it's not true like uh
Crowder was shouting out landau's comedy
dates and stuff and I'm like look man
I'm not here to get into fights with
with people like Crowder or Candace or
whatever because I got no idea what
their thing is you know what I mean it
had nothing to do with me they're
already fighting with me and I'm a far
more formidable foe oh yeah yeah they're
coming after Sheamus no I'm fighting
with you I'm saying you you already have
this war with me all right right right
you know like I woke up in the morning
and all the potatoes were gone yeah
that's true I was like you want to make
racist jokes I'll show you I'll take all
the potatoes but it really backfired
because I was like why is Sheamus have
all the potatoes I was like it's not
like it's well it actually fired because
we were gonna make hash browns for
Sheamus for breakfast yeah we couldn't
find the potatoes oh actually that was
really thoughtful of you guys very
hurtful to your Irish heart it was it I
just felt it was like that actually
would have that would have been
enjoyable and it was a thoughtful plan
yeah and we were gonna sprinkle love the
salt on it that's right it's a special
kind of very special salt did you do it
tomorrow maybe uh you have to give back
the potatoes yeah that's not going to
happen but okay so all right what do we
got lithium cross says could all this be
a media purging campaign a lot of big
personalities have been either removed
or attacked James O'Keefe being Where it
All Began isn't that crazy James O'Keefe
Don Lemon Tucker Carlson Nate silver
BuzzFeed news in its entirety wow I
didn't even know about the James O'Keefe
thing until like a couple hours ago what
happened why was he fired from Veritas
he resigned he was ousted put on leave
yeah because a letter circulated within
the company accusing him of just
impropriety which was clearly BS like
Financial no well sort of they claimed
that he he like was using company funds
for a wedding but it was like a Veritas
what I what so there's two stories first
they said he used company funds for his
wedding venue then someone said no that
was for the Veritas corporate party and
then someone else said actually it was
for his wedding when that got canceled
he just used it it for the Veritas party
and I'm like I literally don't care so
like it took James O'Keefe as far as I'm
concerned should be getting paid five
times as much money than he is we can
see the 990s for Veritas we saw how much
he was making I think it was like 300 to
400k or whatever and I'm like this dude
got raided by the feds is doing some of
those consequential journals in the
world if anyone deserves to be wealthy
off their job it's James O'Keefe so the
fact that they were like and he used the
money to uh set up a corporate party but
it was really because he couldn't get a
refund back for a wedding I'm like so
what well I don't care if the company
bought him a McLaren you know like give
the guy a trophy made a gold the real
story is he went undercover to marry
somebody that's right yeah he was
filming them the entire time when he
wanted to like live out a whole marriage
with some lefties so he could really
really expose him that's why they were
allowed to have Veritas pay for the
wedding all right what is this what is
this uh essay federali Max is actually
grifting Candace went low Stephen never
did anything wrong who's Max what are
they referring to
Max Max who
no idea yeah who's Max all right scrubby
MC scrubberson says Tim emman Bundy put
on FBI Most Wanted list issued default
judgment by judge and property was
surrounded he held a massive barbecue to
avoid a standoff
we had him on the show it was great
all right Martin Edgar says stand your
grounds needs to be a triple shot
cappuccino blend
oh my god well that's that's a challenge
um espresso Blends are darker and that
has less caffeine in it you know lighter
roasts have more caffeine so we would we
would want to do like a light espresso
roast so that it would probably have a
higher caffeine concentration you know
all right
infernal Saxon says Wizards of the Coast
sent to the pinkertons after someone I
don't know if you guys heard the story
but Wizards of the Coast they uh they
make magic the Gathering there's this
guy he got sent a set of cards that
hasn't come out yet and what he thinks
happened is there's a set called
um
what is it what is it called something
machines or whatever and then there was
a new set that's got the same name it
says aftermath he went to a dealer who
said I've got these boxes he bought them
then he realized wait wait these don't
come out for a week you know or for like
two weeks so we made a video about it
and then was it the coast hired the
Pinkerton Security Agency to go to his
house and Shake him down and seize his
property from him and he gave it to him
that's the weirdest thing why would you
do that I don't know I don't have a
right to this he was like they were they
were sold in hands they'd replace the
product and they're trying to figure out
how it got out and what he said was he
thinks someone sent it out by accident
but I don't care if I if I legitly
purchase something yeah and a private
security company to my house yeah the
first thing I'm going to say is by
entering my property you're already
committing burglary because we have a
physical barrier so you can GTFO right
now or I will defend my property dude is
this the nerd John Wick who ends up
fighting a bunch of private security
task force people to the death because
he got yeah it'd be better if it was
like no if they break into his house
yeah exactly they come into his house to
take his Yugo cards and he just gets
into a gunfight with them I mean John
Wick was over a puppy though right we
all understand that we can understand
look it's it's a lovable little dog this
dude is alive his wife got him the dog
when she died right right and so they
killed the dog John Wick's awesome I
gotta watch part four I haven't seen it
I gotta watch it either yeah it just
came out
John looks a good good story the first
one's the best one the rest are just
good fun yeah but the first one's like
such a good story yeah I saw the first
one I I didn't see any of the other ones
yeah
all right essay Federalists mug Club is
the best thing since Murdoch became but
Bud Light what let's make a sponsorship
now for to Carlson and Zero Hedge I'd
pay uh more than my mortgages
I mean that's up to them you know I
don't know what Tucker Carlson's gonna
do it's going to be up to them to start
something
all right servey Rose seviro says please
stop calling cbdc's crypto they may be
ledgers and they may use blockchain as a
data store but they are not
decentralized crypto doesn't mean
decentralized
so and there's a lot of cryptocurrencies
that are centralized like ethereum is I
believe ethereum for the most part is
centralized I actually have a question
about I was asking a friend who knows
much more about this than I do and you
guys do too but about the the new
currency so isn't the whole purpose of
blockchain that you don't create anymore
right there's only a founded amount out
there no no Bitcoin is fine okay
dogecoins not dogecoin's inflationary
okay so dogecoin's actually fairly smart
and although it's based on a meme people
need to understand like it's it's kind
of legit
um I do own a little bit full disclosure
but the idea with Dogecoin is that the
monetary Supply increases by a certain
percentage every year so that there is a
controlled volume increase which does
make sense so with this new currency
would the FED still have the ability to
be able to to yes create money
easily they would never right they would
never issue a currency that they
couldn't create and manipulate and make
more of so then what exactly is the
difference between what we're talking
about and just cash or like cash in the
form of numbers action is tracked in a
ledger so they can see everywhere you've
gone plug it into an AI and then follow
you every step of your existence well
cbdcs are also programmable so they can
prevent you from spending your money on
certain purchases like guns so this is
terrible yeah absolutely yeah very bad
for us so it's what will happen is
there are things you do in your life
that you do not realize correlate so
what we found is Facebook for instance
knows when you poop they know when
you're going to poop yeah because what
they found is I'm not on Facebook do
they know what happened yes yes they do
are on Facebook you're wrong right
Facebook has something called Shadow
profiles you know Shadow profile yeah
yeah totally so what they'll do is
they'll say if a person moves three
meters in you know within a span of 20
seconds and then stops and pauses and
it's between the time period of 7 A.M
and 9 pm there is a 73.9 chance they'll
go to the bathroom within 10 minutes
because the the AI can see patterns we
can't see right so now plug in a cbdc
central bank digital currency they will
have pre-crime they will say there is a
97 chance that when someone goes to this
location and to that location a day
later they will purchase a narcotic from
this location and they will be waiting
for you with pre-crime agents and an old
man being like precogs have found that
you are going to buy drugs and then
you'll be like uh this is something for
people to understand about the
censorship industrial complex because I
think people probably think of it as
like a bunch of you know spies and Hall
monitors just like doing Google Google
searches looking for people spreading
this quote unquote disinformation or
Twitter searches whatever
um and that is some of it but most of it
the overwhelming majority of it was
driven by AI so already like I'm not
talking about the future I'm talking
about like like the Stanford internet
Observatory and all these groups would
would had AI algorithms that would run
that would I run sort of searches based
on themes and then they would catch you
know as many hundreds of thousands and
millions of social media posts within
that bucket and then they would send it
to the to the platforms so that was
already happening the AI is getting
better and better the future that we're
afraid of with the censorship industrial
complex stuff is that you know it's all
going to be run on AI and the AI is
going to dwarf what we have now it's
already everything that you see
everything that you read everything that
you post is going to be filtered through
AI that either increases it or throttles
it for for viewers and you know controls
what you see and that's what they're
trying to construct that's the so I
think it's already been constructed yeah
and we're just seeing the surface that's
already existed for a long time
all right here's a scary one David
Kirkpatrick said Sandy Spring Bank had
to pull 21 million out of reserves to
cover losses and is now laying off 60.
this is driven by the fed's rate
increases the bank did too many low rate
loans and is losing money
yeah I think
it's uh
gonna collapse and then they're gonna
introduce cbdc the the working Theory I
have maybe I'm wrong I don't know I
don't know how probability is is that
they're gonna there's gonna be a bunch
of banks that collapse they're going to
come in and say you've been rescued
download our app and we will transfer
your funds into uh you know gov coin or
whatever they'll call it
and then people are going to do with
Glee they're going to be like oh no my
money's all gone the bank collapsed and
they're gonna what's gonna happen is the
Republicans are going to be like no no
no and the Democrats are going to be
like yes yes yes and people are going to
be like the Democrats need like the
government needs to do this how am I
supposed to pay my employees how am I
supposed to pay my bills and then
everyone's going to go and vote Democrat
the Democrats are going to rubber stamp
the cbdc and then your bank is going to
dissolve but the app will have all of
your funds in it
here it comes
yep they will make you beg for the
servitude
that's smart you know if you try to
impose this on people they're going to
resist you make them beg you for it yeah
the censorship stuff people are this is
this is or this is organ it's coming
from the top down but it's also coming
from the bottom up people are demanding
this stuff
all right let's get some more Super
chats oh yeah I got I have to point
something out Luke's still talking smack
on the chat and he missed a great
opportunity for opponent I'm gonna I'm
gonna Luke I want you to be better at
this so I'm gonna critique your insults
he said Sheamus or Shameless is already
on the leprechaun coin it should you
should have said leprecoin I mean it's
unbelievable it does say leprechaun
leprecoin coin then he's then he wrote
coin twice
foolish two coins that's how you get
inflation idiot
yeah it looks so dumb so dumb get better
at it bro all right Sam says in Back to
the Future too in 2015 Marty is asked to
donate to a charity by thumbing a
hundred dollars by scanning his thumb
for a funds transfer isn't it funny that
Back to the Future 2 took place in 2015
and it was exactly it was exactly like
that I know I mean it's crazy because in
2015 I was riding around Times Square on
a hoverboard while like sharks and
dinosaurs were coming out of the heads
this is what we do have the 3D ads
though now you know if you go to Times
Square and you look at the ad it's bent
and you can it looks like you know
three-dimensional really yeah yeah the
way because it's uh it's at an angle and
then the way the video is so if you're
looking straight at it from one side it
looks really weird but if you're
standing at the right angle it looks
three-dimensional like it's coming out
of the end well yeah some Blade Runner
what do we got next Joe Spinell says
BlackRock increased its stock ownership
of fox to over 15 in February I'm pretty
certain those at BlackRock aren't fans
of Tucker
yep
Tyler Bachman says I have narcolepsy I
take modafinil you're good for about
eight to twelve hours have it
encountered dry skin in the five years
I've been taking the drug the drug is
one of three drugs that allows me to
have a relatively normal life
oh wow
Captain Caveman says it's James Ian's
replacement asking for a friend
no Sheamus is Luke's replacement that's
right
yeah Ian's just uh where is he knocked
straight into the camera that's right
you're never coming back Luke this is my
seat now
enjoy enjoy obscurity well you know
we'll do to be fair to Luke to nothing
we'll give Luke 48 hours to come back
and if he doesn't we'll write Sheamus on
the chair that's right it's my chair you
won't be so so there you go you're
afraid we are change rights Shameless
likes to drink bug light as he tries to
kick helpless dogs Luke you should say
that a fourth time in chat I bet it'll
get even funnier is it the fourth time
you said it it's like the fourth time he
said it yeah bug light bug Light I think
he bugs he doesn't know how to spell he
was thinking he says no one can replace
me well to be you know Luke you're right
so if you're here within 48 hours we'll
give you your chair back otherwise we're
writing Sheamus on it sure that's right
I will I will take a silver paint marker
and I will write Sheamus on the chair oh
that's kind of hurt
[Laughter]
um Captain Caveman says what's a
potato's favorite TV show starch Trek
wow uh I heard someone someone in chat
uh who actually made a clever pun about
Bud Light said Spotlight is what I drink
but I said that's pretty good
this potato thing all started because I
was watching leprechaun I think it was
Leprechaun 2 I'm not sure yes and
Sheamus walks in and he's like what are
you watching and he looks the screen and
there's a guy turning Irish because he
got bit by a leprechaun and he orders
from the waitress this is really happens
to the movie he's like I want mashed
potatoes french fries tater tots and and
waffle fries and he's eating a whole
bunch of different french fries and
Sheamus just turns and sees this guy and
he's like what is this this is the most
racist thing I've ever seen I can't
believe this but no no joke the guy gets
bitten by the leprechaun and starts
turning Irish that's literally what
happens yeah and he starts embodying all
these Irish stereotypes potatoes this is
this is our representation in media but
the messed up thing is potatoes aren't
even endemic to Ireland that's a lie
it's a dirty lie they were introduced
stop it stop it there's a liar you're
like no that is true technically but so
so basically it's metaphorically false
the Leprechaun movie was using the
Potato Famine as like a stereotype about
I people because they didn't have
because they didn't have potatoes you
you could say anything about it listen
Irish people weren't considered white
until being white men you had to
apologize for being white all the time
like is just where the group that
everyone can make fun of and crap on but
we're gonna get sick of it Jonathan Howe
says Tim please get Tucker on IRL yes
like I love when people are just like
you should have Trump on the show I'm
like yeah we should
all right you should get Tucker
you know and Brad Pitt maybe Tom Cruise
listening don't come on Tim doesn't
deserve it he doesn't deserve your
presence come on to shamer rumble.com
we reached out to Tucker's team and he
he is cognizant of the desire he is
aware and we'll see what happens it's up
to him you know we'll have him out when
he wants to come out maybe when he's
launching his show he'll come here and
announce it we'll be like a big thing
where he's like here's my new show it's
amazing it's called
shamer I'm stealing his podcast like
what Tucker's just stealing podcast
he snaps his fingers and then two guys
come and just carry you out of the room
are you guys right you cross out Sheamus
on my chair and write Tucker on it
yeah Luke has been replaced Luke first
it was Sheamus now it's me
all right what do we got John Kirsten
says Tyler Fisher Jordan Peterson
impersonation is greater than potato
man's Jordan impersonation impression I
mean if you want to debase yourself by
lying in the chat that's fine but just
know you'll be held accountable for it
okay yeah
um what did we just said I just had a
superintendent just jumped away from me
where did it go it said something about
uh
I can't I can't find it you know when
the super chats come in it'll load a
whole bunch and then just jump ahead
yeah yeah
uh Matt zarella says Bud Light when you
don't want to lose money but you want to
lose a lot of it
well so the joke is Bud Light is the
beer for people who don't want to drink
beer but want to drink a lot of it but
that makes sense because like I don't
really want to drink any beer but you
want to get drunk whereas like you don't
want to lose money but you want to lose
a lot of it it's like I don't know
but I get it they're losing money
what is this one Tenny ball says I'm a
St Louis native home of the
Anheuser-Busch Brewery apology or not
they are dead to me thankfully Yingling
is available over here now that's cool
because it's like an East Coast thing
they're good yeah it's good stuff it's
like a DC thing right middle all right
yeah yeah yeah PA it's a Pennsylvania
beer but it's like all over the place
out here and I noticed like everybody
orders it it's like the thing to order
you know and then the further you go
west it disappears which is weird
because it's like sad too I don't think
like New York it's is it on tap we
should make Yingling the replacement for
Bud Light everybody insists that your
bar carry this brand yeah uh you know no
Tim we gotta make uh Ultra Sheamus's
beer well there there is to be fair this
conservative dad's Ultra right beer
heard about that we ordered 600 cans of
it
yeah I I recommend against drinking
alcohol by the way I really do really
yeah I think it's bad yeah well it's
definitely bad but it's also fun well
I'd say it can be good in moderation if
you're an adult yeah proper legal
drinking age then you can make the
decision for yourself but me I think
it's it's no no is Bueno knows but I
understand you know it's because people
can't control himself he gets one Sip
and he goes ah it's happening it's
happening give me more
I'll drink the Bud Light I don't care
Derek mensen says Sheamus talks big for
a guy from a country that looks like the
Apple logo with the UK taking a bite out
of it
first of all I never talk big all right
secondly I'm really from America don't
tell anybody all right everybody if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
become a member at timcast.com we're
going to have a members only uncensored
show coming up live in about 10 minutes
on the front page of timcast.com to
watch it just become a member at
timcast.com by clicking join us you'll
also have there'll also be instructions
on how to join the Discord server so you
can hang out with like-minded
individuals don't forget to also
purchase some cast brew coffee because
pre-orders are about to hit and they
will be delivering by shipping out by
May 5th first come first serves as a lot
of people who've already purchased this
is amazing we've sold enough products to
basically replace sponsorships we're
really excited for it there's a few that
we're keeping on because we're big fans
of some of these companies so again go
to timcast.com smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends Leighton you want to
shout anything out up sure oh like plug
yeah whatever you want to shout out oh
yeah I'll plug myself there you go um
public.substack.com is our subtech
that's me and Michael schellenberger
um you can hit me up on Twitter at
Elwood house uh what else do you want to
say do you have anything any uh
whistleblower whistleblower leaks to
send you can send it to laytonwoodhouse
at proton dot me right on I can send you
some stuff about uh Tim cast and Luke
we'll talk about a little bit about Luke
Luke
thank you all for watching I'm gonna
level with you Tim is a bad man with a
Dark Soul if you want political
commentary for someone who isn't evil
you can check out rumble.com shame and
you're able to watch me and you see I
let him say these things I believe in
free speech that's right he believes in
it so much the capitalist will sell us
the rope with which we will hang them
uh Tim Poole will give me the platform
with which I will expose him but if you
want to check out my podcast it's
rumble.com shamer and I also make
cartoons at a YouTube channel called
Freedom Tunes I have an awesome team we
churn out this content we released a
really funny cartoon today and we're
gonna have one out Thursday so keep your
eyes peeled for it kids
Adrian Norman DC on all platforms other
than true social and Rumble which is
just Adrian Norman right on and uh
answers.com on Twitter find me and let's
argue we will see all of you over at
timcast.com in about 10 minutes thanks
for hanging out